Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Ich habe gehört es gibt gute nachrichten.
Da fällt mir jetzt nicht so ein.
Buchner politik nummer dreihundertsechsundvierzig vom zwanzigsten mai zwanzig zwanzig und ja doch das gerücht hält sich linus das gerücht hält sich.
Das gerücht mit den positiven nachrichten.
Ich habe davon was gehört oder bist du da bist du ja nicht ganz so der meinung.
Doch doch ich bin der meinung aber wie du weißt ich kann ja mit mit guten nachrichten können wir gar nicht so gut umgehen da haben wir das eigene musik für geschaffen hier.
Deswegen haben wir ein ein gast in der heutigen sendung den wir vorstellen möchten.
So ist es und zwar begrüßen wir den daniel daniel mosbrugger hallo.
Hallo ich grüße euch.
Ja herzlich willkommen bei logbuch netzpolitik es hat natürlich einen guten grund wir werden heute sehr viel über das gesetz also das urteil zum gesetz sprechen was beim verfassungsgericht gestern.
Kündet wurde.
Ja und du bist in gewisser hinsicht qualifiziert da drüber zu sprechen vielleicht kannst du uns ja mal kurz und den hörerinnen und hörern sagen was du eigentlich,
normalerweise so tust.
Normalerweise also ich bin sozusagen von pike auf beruflich journalist
und bin dann zweitausendsechzehn zu der menschenrechtsorganisation reporter ohne grenzen gegangen als referent für internetfreiheit und zweitausendsechzehn die menschen die sich auch mit dem gesetz.
Beschäftigt haben eingehender der klingelt vielleicht gleich das war genau das jahr wo das dann losging und ich habe bis sommer jetzt neunzehn bei reporter ohne grenzen gearbeitet und habe da
ziemlich intensiv eigentlich an dem verfahren mitgearbeitet vor allen dingen auf seite der beschwerdeführer aber wir waren selber auch welche und bin jetzt seit
letzten sommer nicht mehr hauptamtlich bei weil ich ein bisschen zeit für meine dissertation brauche habe aber jetzt die organisation ehrenamtlich noch weiterhin unterstützt und war im
januar bei der mündlichen verhandlung war gestern in karlsruhe und ja hab.
Alle akten gelesen berufsmäßig auch die nicht öffentlichen und habe viel erfahren und mich gestern gefreut und ja.
Je länger ich lese freue ich mich an manchen stellen auch nicht mehr so aber da können wir ja gleich mal drüber reden.
Dass du seit sommer neunzehn bei mit der hauptamtlichen tätigkeit aufgehört hast wissen übrigens vielleicht einige weil ich mich erinnere dass wir damals auf die stellenausschreibungen aufmerksam gemacht haben.
Verbunden mit einem lob deiner arbeit wie das so ist.
Vielen dank ich habe es gehört.
Das freut mich
wir haben heute eine mehr oder weniger monothematisch sendung wollen aber einmal ganz kurz noch auf das feedback eingehen und zwar hat time in der letzten sendung behauptet er würde einmal die woche fünf minuten einkaufen,
und dieser äußerung wurde mit neid und argwohn begegnet tim erkläre dich wie schaffst du es in fünf minuten einzukaufen.
Habe in dem moment so ein paar sachen verdreht aber es gibt tatsächlich einen ort den ich in fünf minuten komplett abgegrast bekomme und das ist der getränkemarkt
ja also da da ist es wirklich roll on roll off und ich bin schnell wieder raus und natürlich ist es im normalen supermarkt,
schwierig trotz alledem es gilt wenn man seinen supermarkt,
kennt kann man die wege optimieren ich habe da auch eine spezielle einkaufsliste auf meinem telefon die denn das immer schon so nach sektionen sortiert und so man denn dann auch in ein supermarkt kommt der dieser,
etwas folgt dann ist es etwas einfacher aber ich gebe zu auch ich brauche im supermarkt länger als fünf minuten.
Ich kriege den supermärkten regelmäßig nervenzusammenbrüche und ich ich kann das also überhaupt nicht,
supermärkte ist nichts für mich da muss ich mir wirklich zeit nehmen ich mache aber in letzter zeit öfter einkäufe für andere leute,
und das habe ich auch gedacht so warum soll man nicht auch mal was was was harte also mal richtig dahingehen wo es wehtut um seinen freunden zu helfen in supermarkt mit einer einkaufsliste von jemand anders tim.
Vorstellen wie geil das ist.
Das ist noch herz.
Inzwischen habe ich mir überlegt ich freunde mich damit dem personal an.
Und dann gehe ich da einfach hin gib dir den zettel und trink so lange kaffee oder sowas ja und sagt kommt mach mach fertig.
Ist egal was kostet macht klar ihr wisst auch für die scheiße steht.
Es gibt auch lieferdienste aber es gibt da keine termine bei den lieferdienste das ist das.
Ja deswegen bin ich der lieferdienst.
Lieferdienst linus neumann aber.
Nur für freunde.
Nur für freunde ja ok apropos du gehst dahin wo es richtig weh tut du bist auch gerade wieder irgendwohin gegangen wo es richtig weh tut.
Also ich hoffe nicht dass ich mir dass ich mir da weh getan habe ich war hier war ja am samstag eine reihe an corona demos in berlin.
Und entgegen der eindringlichen warnhinweise meiner freunde die sagt linus das sind impfgegner ohne mundschutz überleg dir das bitte gut.
Bin ich da mal hingegangen habe mir das korona demonstrationsgeschehen am am samstag in berlin angeschaut es gab eine also wirklich eine ganze menge an demonstrationen und ich wollte das mal kurz schildern also es ist ja so,
es gibt ja eine reihe.
Würde ich sagen nachvollziehbarer und legitimer protest anlässe die kitas haben zu was eine massive belastung für
familien ist und noch massivere belastung für alleinerziehende du hast keinen zugang zu angehörigen die in irgendwelchen
institutionen die du in institutionen abgeschoben hast oder so ne also all das altersheim oder sowas die gastronomie ist geschlossen seit
monaten inzwischen jetzt ja gerade wieder in berlin die öffnung sehr zu sehr zu beobachten im stadtbild.
Allerdings zum beispiel kneipen müssen wenn sie keine küche haben immer noch geschlossen haben das kommt dann jetzt in den.
Kommt dann jetzt in den dritten monat ne alle dürfen weiter miete zahlen das thema bier hier lange genug behandelt jetzt gestern habe ich,
spiegel online gesehen einreiseverbot nach malotze ja also es gibt es gibt eine ganze reihe wirklich,
speckte gegen die man gerade demonstrieren kann und wo man fundierte politische meinung zu bilden äußern kann oder auch einfach nur interessen.
Ballermann.
Was ist denn los ja da da gab's auch schon vor einem monat diese diese leute die die ferienwohnung auf mallorca haben und dann irgendwie dem bürgermeister dort geschrieben haben oder dem gouverneur von.
Von mallorca oder was auch immer wir da als stadthalter installiert haben dass sie das nicht einsehen dass ihr quasi werden das alles aufgebaut hier und dass sie jetzt von ihrem eigentum ferngehalten werden soll also da gibt's es gibt eine ganze reihe sache über die man,
gegen die oder über die man protestieren kann die auch nachvollziehbar sind die habe ich da allerdings nicht gesehen ja.
Ich habe eher gesehen sagen wir mal etwas.
Einfachere forderungen ja also einer einmal mein lieblingsschild war selber den kennen.
Informieren statt manipulieren widerstand also ich glaube dass leute ein wortspiel sein ausdenken und candy hetzen was.
Oh gott.
Also aus den beiden worten ein wortspiel machen kann ist wirklich sehr unterhaltsam ne.
Den oh gott.
Das ist so wie hammel ein wortspiel aus himmel und hölle hat auch nichts miteinander zu tun kennen jetzt nur denken himmel und hölle und dann.
Sofortiger untersuchungsausschuss corona bitte waschen sie ihre hände ihr gehirn waschen wir die öffentlich-rechtlichen.
Haben die ernsthafte gehabt.
Gehirn waschen.
Wer wie was wieso weshalb warum ja.
Auch sehr schön wer gegen einschränkungen der grundrechte eintritt ist kein verschwörungstheoretiker das da haben wir wieder ich sag ja die haben alle probleme mit epidemiologische weil,
nur weil du gegen einschränkungen der grundrechte eintritt heißt dass weder dass du verschwörungstheoretikers bist noch dass du keiner bist das sind zwei relativ unabhängige
dinge die nichts miteinander zu tun haben also es gibt sowohl verschwörungstheorie tasten die.
Gegen einschränkung der grundrechte eintreten als auch welche die dafür eintreten dass er hat einfach nichts miteinander zu tun.
Meine lieblings auftritt war aber dann so ein hier wie heißt das wenn man an den wenn man an den mundwinkeln so weiße.
Weißt du ja nicht noch nicht vorm mund aber so am rand also.
So speisereste.
Nee sprechblase heißt das.
Ach sprech klasse.
Wenn du dich so eifers dass du schon trockenen mund hast und der speichel schäumt und bitte zu.
Ablagerung ja ja.
Ja ja das sieht immer sage ich mal der.
Ist in der regel dem argument nicht unbedingt zuträglich aber er hat auf jeden fall meine aufmerksamkeit gefunden weil er beschwerte sich.
Zurecht über die architektur am alexanderplatz,
aber jetzt ist natürlich schwierig wenn du am alexanderplatz in berlin stehst wenn du dann das system kritisieren willst was diese architektur hervorgebracht hat weil je nachdem auf welches gebäude du da zeigst haben dass die kapitalisten gebaut oder die kommunisten
ja habe ich gedacht okay gegen wen richtet er sich jetzt naja stellt sich raus er war der meinung die könige hatten einen sinn für ästhetik also ein monarchie ist.
Der dann nach einer längeren ausführung über das system und schweinesystem alles schon gehört dann von der polizei auch gebeten wurde,
doch diese
ansammlung ein bisschen zu vermeiden dann hat er die da ihr habt einen schuhe geschworen dass sie deutsche volk und so in einer wasserdruck zu hat er dann die kurve zu den rothschilds und was nicht alles bekommen.
Dabei wurde mir dann klar dieser.
Also diese diese situation war interessant und verfahren.
Aber was ich eigentlich spannend fand war und das ist da hätte man sich zum beispiel auch durchaus darüber beschweren können über die einschränkungen der versammlungsfreiheit denn,
ich habe mich erst ich habe mich erst gewundert warum die so viele,
demonstrationen angemeldet hatten das lag aber daran dass die dass die auflage war dass ich maximal fünfzig personen versammeln dürfen.
Und das wurde jeweils realisiert mit absperrungen das heißt du hattest da deine deine demonstration jetzt deine hattest deine versammlung angemeldet ja dann haben sie dir gesagt okay du darfst nur fünfzig personen haben
und dann musstest du dir quasi auch ein so mit flatterband war dann quasi eingezeichnet hier versammlung.
So man durfte aber jetzt auch nicht anhalten um zu gucken man durfte nur entweder teilnehmen dann musste man sich an den mindestabstand halten ich hätte eigentlich auch gedacht dass eine masken- pflicht besteht die haben aber.
Der größere teil der leute nicht wahrgenommen und,
das hat auch ein bisschen mir probleme bereitet mich da so ungesehen drunter zu mischen weil ich selbstverständlich eine maske an hatte wie gesagt ne impfgegner ohne mundschutz erziehst du lieber selber zwei an und deswegen konnte ich mich da jetzt nicht so ganz drunter mischen.
Dann kam halt irgendwann aber auch wenn man da mal da so gesteht gestanden hat kam dann so die polizei hat einen gebeten weiterzugehen da muss man natürlich schon sagen also das finde ich jetzt nicht das ist für mich nicht versammlungsfreiheit wenn du sagst du machst eine demonstration an einem zentralen
ort in der stadt ja und defacto werden menschen gehindert.
Deine kundgebung dazu folgen also es war quasi so die mussten auch durchsagen so wir sind jetzt fünfzig leute jetzt kann keiner mehr mitmachen jetzt müsst ihr gehen.
Ja dann da musstest du zu der nächsten versammlung oder so gehen also das denke ich das waren keine dauerhaft tragbaren regelungen für für versammlungsfreiheit.
Da auch da denke ich hätte man sich durchaus beschweren können gleichzeitig aber also ich hatte halt irgendwie den eindruck es gibt eine ganze menge.
Sachen zu denen man gerade was sagen kann aber die schienen da halt echt nicht vertreten zu sein und auch irgendwie.
Frage ich mich halt ne was die scheinen auch.
Ich hatte den eindruck dass die menschen jetzt auch so von den wirklichen problemen nicht betroffen sind da stand jetzt nicht jemand hier ihr tötet die gastronomie in berlin oder sowas ne das war dann nicht vertreten das war er hier so
der öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk muss muss weg oder so war sehr.
Ein sehr mulmiges gefühl muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen was ich da so an leuten versammelt hat also ich habe das irgendwie der der der der sammelbegriff der mir da irgendwie nachher übergeblieben ist war esoterische nazi hippies.
Jetzt gibt's wieder ärger von unserer fraktion es gibt natürlich auch hippies die sind richtige hippies aber.
Ja es gibt aber es gibt auch nicht alle hippies sind esoterische nazi hippies ne das muss man auf jeden fall ganz klar sagen.
Und die waren aber aber das waren die waren da ja du hast ja auch hier die typen auf twitter gesehen ne der virus existiert nicht wir müssen uns jetzt alle umarmen die fraktion war auch vertreten.
Es war wirklich ich hatte ich kann's nicht anders sagen ich hatte da eine mulmiges gefühl bei der beobachtung dieser ansammlung von menschen nicht nur wegen des infektionsrisiko sondern auch wegen der.
Doch recht ja hilf hilflosen und ziellosen richtung ihres ihre ihrer unmut bekundungen.
Was ist wahrscheinlich einfach macht wenn er jetzt mal jemand hinkommt und den eine richtung gibt und wer das wer sich darauf wer darauf gerade abzieht ist uns ja auch allen bekannt.
Wie schön du deine nachmittage gestaltest.
Samstagnachmittag habe ich mir gegeben.
Sag nochmal einer es wäre nichts los in berlin.
Also es war eine menge los so viele demonstrationen gab's glaube ich selten in berlin aber wie gesagt die waren halt auch alle auf fünfzig limitiert und ich denke dass es so dass es so eigentlich nicht nicht haltbar es gab ja dann auch noch das habe ich aber leider verpasst weil er wollte ich wollte ich,
da wollte ich war so eine mischung aus faszination und und angst diese versammlung die dann vor dem reichstag stattfinden sollte wozu dieser könig der,
verschwörung tasten da aufgerufen hatte aber das habe ich mir dann ja dieser attila hildmann.
Der hat ja auch irgendwie ja das habe ich mir dann nicht mehr gegeben.
Kommen wir doch lieber zu der frage wie die abstandsregelung in karlsruhe so eingehalten werden das würde mich auch mal interessieren.
Die richter haben tatsächlich.
Vor das eigentliche richter pult tische gestellt so provisorische tische und die gesamte richter bank ging dann wirklich durch den gesamten raum damit die richterinnen und richter
so eineinhalb bis zwei meter abstand hatten und dafür keine maske tragen mussten.
Hatten sie auch jeder einen einkaufswagen.
Hallo.
Also mit anderen worten das ganze fand in dem saal statt wo es auch sonst stattfand aber man hat vielleicht die fenster aufgemacht.
Nee das hat man auch nicht gemacht man hat nur ich war ja im januar vierzehnter zehnter war es glaube ich war die mündliche verhandlung für zwei tage und da war wirklich der
der saal der gerichtssaal komplett voll da waren schätzungsweise hundert leute drin und dann rundrum waren noch besucher ringe das waren sicherlich auch nochmal hundert leute die die presse grüne ging glaube ich dreißig,
dieses mal waren glaube ich im gerichtssaal selber vielleicht so fünfzehn maximal zwanzig
besucher wurden zehn zugelassen und ich glaube journalisten auch irgendwie zehn also da war im vergleich von vor vier monaten war da quasi nichts los.
Ok wir reden natürlich von der verkündung des urteils,
zur klage gegen das gesetz das ist jetzt hier unser kernthema.
Ja vielleicht kannst du daniel uns das ja mal ein bisschen einsortieren
wie es denn eigentlich dazu kam also vielleicht blättern wir auch nochmal ein bisschen weiter zurück damit auch klar ist worüber wir jetzt hier genau
reden was genau ist dieses bild gesetz und wie kam es dazu dass wir jetzt in dieser situation waren an der du gestern teilgenommen hast.
Also wenn man ganz weit zurückblättern würde dann müssten wir irgendwann im kalten krieg anfangen als die sogenannte strategische fernmeldeamt aufklärung,
der den einzug in die deutsche rechtsordnung gefunden hat das will ich uns jetzt mal ersparen ich würde mal zweitausenddreizehn
anfangen und zwar wie man das bei dem thema massenüberwachung doch immer wieder tun sollte bei adwords noten der ja erstmal gegen die vor allen dingen gegen die
dokumente veröffentlicht hatte und dann gab es ja in deutschland den untersuchungsausschuss
der bis zum ende offiziell auch so hieß inoffiziell war es natürlich dann irgendwann längst ein untersuchungsausschuss geworden.
Weil ja glaube ich während des untersuchungsausschusses immer wieder klar wurde wie eng eigentlich die
partnerschaft zwischen dem bundesnachrichtendienst und der und den anderen westlichen diensten eigentlich ist das hängt vor allen dingen natürlich mit der geografischen lage deutschlands zusammen
wir haben unter anderem das ticket in frankfurt einem der größten wenn nicht sogar dem größten internetknoten punkt der welt wo sich der bnd.
Technisch bedienen kann und rechtlich auch darf und ja.
Das lief ja dann bis so zwo.
Sechzehn glaube ich eine zu sechzehn wurde der abschlussbericht des untersuchungsausschusses vorgelegt aber es wurde ja dann schon.
Vorher klar okay
wir haben dann so dinge wie die weltraum theorie erfahren also dass der bmw im weltraum nicht an grundrechte gebunden ist wenn er im weltall satelliten abhört und so weiter funktionsträgern theorie da gehe ich vielleicht gleich nochmal darauf ein was das nochmal genau war also wir haben auf jeden fall gehört
irgendwie so ganz koscher ist das nicht was da läuft das hat dann auch die große koalition.
Eingesehen hat das gesetz reformiert das gesetz gibt es natürlich schon länger und hat aber und das ist so der kern dessen worum es jetzt ging die sogenannte ausland ausland fernmeldeamt aufklärung,
ja zum ersten mal wirklich rechtlich in deutschland geregelt vielleicht einmal ausland ausland was ist jetzt damit gemeint.
Ausland meint ausländische personen also,
menschen die nicht innerhalb der eu wohnen das ist da die der oder sich aufhalten die idee
plus die sich zum zeitpunkt der überwachung auch noch dort aufhalten man könnte auch sagen die ganz weit weg sind von der eu wobei die so weit weg gar nicht,
sein müssen also türkei wäre auch schon ausland ausland die sind nicht in der eu und wenn jetzt der bmw in der türkei überwacht dann wäre das ausland ausland fernmeldeamt aufklärung und,
dagegen da gab es dann eben das das gesetz für und das gesetz war aber eigentlich nur eine ja eine legalisierung dessen
was man so gehört hatte also da war jetzt nichts im sinne von oh gott der bmw hat voll übertrieben sondern eher so ja klar der bmw macht das und jetzt gehen wir immer das gesetz dafür
und da gab's dann so im sommer zwo sechzehn das war eben dann gerade der punkt als ich auch zu reporter ohne grenzen gekommen war da gab es dann eben den aufschlag und da haben doch doch sehr sehr viele gesagt okay das.
Könnt ihr nicht ernst meinen das ist ja.
Jetzt gibt's hier ein gesetz aber das enthält ja also von der dfb spricht immer von gummiparagraphen und das war's auch ja da steht dann halt drin der.
Darf daten erheben von ausländern ausland wenn's um die handlungsfähigkeit deutschlands geht so ja okay da dachten wir halt auch das wäre seinen job.
Es war doch eigentlich ich würde es ganz sagen ehrlich sagen das war ein handfester skandal dass wir in untersuchungsausschuss in deutschland haben in dem gesetzesverstößen von einem geheimdienst festgestellt werden und noch bevor dieser.
Untersuchungsausschuss abgeschlossen ist wird einfach ein gesetz erlassen was das mehr oder weniger legalisiert das ist wirklich also das fand ich
sowas von unerhört ich glaube in dem zusammenhang tim hattest du da auch da mal den einen meiner lieblingssendung titel dass das gesetz verstößt gegen die geheimdienste den.
Politik hundertneunundfünfzig.
Weil das das ist doch wirklich eine also es war so ich fand's unerhört.
Politisch war das noch frau ja also du hast da irgendwie dass das gewählte organ des volkes ja der bundestag klärt auf klärt ein skandal auf gleichzeitig müssen wir ja auch
betonen snowden wurde nicht gehört aus den aber witzigsten gründen ginge das alles nicht und die bundesregierung versuchte jeden interessanten zeugen irgendwie zu verhindern und im prinzip alles was gerade so rausgekommen war das wurde dann halt ins gesetz geschrieben und
ja legalisiert das war tatsächlich politisch war das ein affront gegen das parlament würde ich würde ich so sagen ja definitiv.
Dieser affront hat dann das hat dann dazu geführt dass sich hier ein widerstand formiert hat in form von.
Weiß nicht wer war da ist alles dabei juristen die dfl also wer hat dann beschlossen dagegen zu klagen.
Genau es war so dass,
politisch da nichts zu machen war also das hat man ja auch wirklich selten vom vom ersten entwurf der so bekannt wurde bis zur verabschiedeten
version im parlament wurde nichts geändert mit nichts manche wirklich nicht
kein einziges komma sich getan obwohl es wirklich proteste gab es gab eine demo vom brandenburger tor wir als reporter ohne grenzen hatten damals ein
bündnis mit dreißig medienmanipulation aus der ganzen welt der uno sonderberichterstatter in brandbrief geschrieben hat gesagt leute das geht so nicht aber das ding wurde durchgezogen
und dann hatten wir.
Also wir als als reporter ohne grenzen gemeinsam mit der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte und eigentlich relativ schnell wir hatten auch in anderen dinge schon zusammengearbeitet relativ schnell gefunden hat und gesagt okay lass uns da was machen uns war es wichtig
das nicht nur alleine zu machen wir haben deswegen das gab's auch noch nie,
alle größeren deutschen medien organisation versammelt also neben reporter ohne grenzen der gf waren das noch der deutschen verband die deutsche journalistin journalistenunion
netzwerk recherche als investigative zwerg und die sich vor allen dingen am osteuropa kümmern wir alle haben am.
Muss man auch sagen geld in den topf gelegt zusammen als organisation es kostet ja auch alles etwas und haben gesagt ok wir machen das mit der gfl gemeinsam und haben dann den matthias,
bäcker professor doktor matthias becker aus mainz,
gewonnen als bevollmächtigten des verfahrens und haben dann ende zweitausend.
Zehn verfassungsbeschwerde gegen das gesetz in karlsruhe eingelegt die.
Interessante sache oder die herausforderung in karlsruhe ist ja immer dass du jetzt das jetzt nicht jedermann oder jede frau einfach so dahin gehen kann sondern du musst ja immer eine betroffenheit.
Deutlich machen du musst immer sagen ich bin hier in meiner grundrechten betroffen und das ist gerade bei überwachungs- gesetze nicht ganz so einfach weil wir seltenes davon erfahren dass wir überwacht wurden
und deswegen haben wir eben um verschiedene aspekte zu zu prüfen zu lassen haben wir eben sehr bewusst,
auch in unseren netzwerken geguckt
okay wer sind personen die hier besonders betroffen sind von diesem neuen gesetz und haben die eben darin unterstützt selbst beschert führerinnen und beschwerdeführer
zu werden und hatten dann unter anderem dabei das ist die trägerin des alternativen nobelpreis,
preises eine sehr renommierte journalistin die viel zu korruption macht hohe muss ein mexikanischer investigativ-journalist wir hatten aber auch.
Einen deutschen dabei der aber in
guatemala bei einem menschenrechtsbildung arbeitet mit ihm wollten wir diese funktionsträgern theorie überprüfen lassen das heißt also die funktionsträgern theorie besagt im ganz kurzen dass der bmw argumentierte okay deutsche
dürfen wir eigentlich nicht überwachen aber wenn die im ausland für jemand anderen arbeiten und zu sagen beruflich kommunizieren dann sind das ja keine deutschen mehr sondern sind die funktionsträgern dieser ausländischen organisation und da dürfen wir sie doch wieder überwachen
na ja und so haben wir uns dann da so ein so eine gruppe zusammengestellt von leuten und sind nach karlsruhe gegangen
und dann ging das verfahren seinen weg.
Und das braucht ja dann einige vorbereitungen und planung sowas dann auch richtig zu machen wir habt ihr euch da organisiert.
Also
die hauptaufgabe tatsächlich das war auch so mit meinem mein hauptjob irgendwann wird's natürlich sehr juristisch also ich muss dazu sagen ich bin kein jurist ich bin journalist und habe mich aber jetzt tief in das thema eingearbeitet
die hauptaufgabe für uns war vor allen dingen
personen zu finden die passen also du musst natürlich diese schwelle erstmal nehmen das karlsruhe sagt ja stimmt die leute hier sind.
Betroffen von diesem grundrechtseingriffen
und das ist bei einer anlasslose massenüberwachung gar nicht so einfach weil natürlich die bundesregierung mit jedem schriftsatz argumentiert,
personen die wir wussten nicht wieso na die können hier nicht keine grundrechtsverschärfungen geltend machen und
ja das war so die hauptaufgabe dann sind schriftsätze ausgetauscht worden.
Von der bundesregierung glaube ich zweimal von uns noch einmal.
Und wir bekamen dann aber so im laufe des jahres zu achtzehn und zwo neunzehn doch ein immer besseres gefühl denn ja ja erstmal wurde das sozusagen nicht sofort ab
gelehnt dann wurde das zugestellt an die bundesregierung dann wurde die bundesregierung doch nochmal gebeten was zu sagen und als wir dann wirklich.
Zuversichtlich wurden dass da zumindest ein bisschen was zu holen ist das war im dezember als dann ziemlich aus heiterem himmel die einladung kam okay es gibt eine mündliche verhandlung
und das ist jetzt in zivil oder strafrechtsprofessorin völlig normal im bundesverfassungsgerichtes ist es ziemlich außergewöhnlich also ich hatte dann nachgeguckt.
Zwo.
Zweitausendneunzehn oder achtzehn weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr genau gab's auf jeden fall so ungefähr so um die dreitausend neue verfahren eingänge im ersten senat und ganze zwei mündliche verhandlung also da merkt man schon okay,
die haben offensichtlich wirklich fragen diese mündliche verhandlung gab es dann im januar was.
Auch persönlich für mich eine extrem spannende erfahrung war weil wirklich,
alle personen die in deutschland dazu irgendwie arbeiten in also die bundesregierung war irgendwie mit fünfzig sechzig leuten da ja da war wirklich so jeder der zu dem thema einiges macht da und ja
vor allen dingen wurde.
Muss auch war auch da muss ich kurz sagen.
Konstante.
Kurz vor da die hat auch dann ich glaube zwei tage später oder sagen wir auch noch locker blockbuch mit ihr aufgenommen muss natürlich kann ich unerwähnt bleiben.
Natürlich nicht nein,
constanze war auch sachverständige genau hat am ende des ersten tages ich erinnere mich noch als alle doch sehr hungrig waren weil irgendwie es gab eine mittagspause dann haben die irgendwie so von vierzehn bis neunzehn dreißig dadurch verhandelt ohne pause
genau und konstanze war eine der letzten glaube ich die am ersten tag was gesagt hatte ja diese mündliche verhandlung die lief dann aber ehrlicherweise ziemlich gut.
Und ja weil eigentlich nur der bnd beziehungsweise die bundesregierung dort fragen beantworten musste
das ding war auch ziemlich interessant also da hat man auch einiges erfahren klar hat der bmw immer wieder gesagt dass man konkrete sachen leider nicht,
sagen können es geht ja immer um staatswohl jede statistik kann die sicherheit des landes gefährden aber trotzdem gab es ein paar sachen einfach auch so um die dimension klar zu bekommen um dies da geht.
Ja also wir haben zum beispiel erfahren dass der bund nur im rahmen dieser ausland ausland fernwert aufklärung jeden tag jeden tag hundertvierundfünfzigtausend kommunikationseinheit alte,
als nachrichtendienstliche relevant
einstuft beziehungsweise die bleiben erstmal hängen sie werden als elektro steuert und spucken dann was aus und pro tag sollen die angeblich sollen diese hundertvierundfünfzigtausend inhalte im schnitt dann.
Gesichtet werden von menschen und daraus werden dann,
zweihundertsechzig im schnitt die wirklich noch nachrichtendienst nicht relevant sind solche dinge hat man dort erfahren
dazu kommen noch ein paar hunderttausend meter daten die jeden tag dort rausgesiebt werden die auch erstmal alle wichtig sind genau ja und.
Dann war es irgendwann klar okay jetzt wird dann bald mal einen brief kommen aus karlsruhe dass das urteil gesprochen wird und das war dann der fall und jetzt wurde gestern das urteil gesprochen.
So nach dieser vorverhandlungen was für ein gefühl hattet ihr dann und wie ging es dann weiter.
Also das gefühl war gut das kann man jetzt nicht verschweigen also es hat aber auch jeder im saal.
Das war irgendwie klar dass jetzt karlsruhe da jetzt nicht uns also sonst hätten sie auch keine mündliche verhandlung gemacht wenn sie da uns völlig hätten ins leere laufen lassen die frage ist halt immer wie viel man kriegt dann und.
Wir waren zuversichtlich und ja sind es auch weiterhin also das urteil was gestern gefällt wurde das ist,
das kann man schon sagen das ist ein meilenstein da sind ein paar dinge entschieden worden die ich fahren ewig auf der tagesordnung in dieser debatte um die sind jetzt geklärt und die sind eigentlich auch alle so geklärt wie man in sich wünschen wollte.
Und es gibt aber ein paar details die unschön sind wo ich den verdacht habe dass die bundesregierung genau diese details sich rauspicken wird um da eine reform des bmw gesetzes vorzulegen
die dann doch nicht mehr ganz so dem gusto des urteils entspricht aber um das vielleicht mal bevor wir so in die in die details gehen,
was wirklich.
Wegweisende grundsatzentscheidung für deutschland das kann man gar nicht kleiner sagen ist ist der erste satz ich würde mir einfach mal rausnehmen den vorzulesen da heißt es nämlich im ersten leitsatz die bindung der deutschen staatsgewalt
an die grundrechte nach artikel eins absatz drei ist nicht auf das deutsche staatsgebiets begrenzt jetzt werden sich manche sagen,
wieso sollte es auch diese ansicht hatten eigentlich auch so ziemlich alle außer die bundesregierung.
Das ist natürlich irgendwie komisch wäre wenn jetzt deutsche behörden im ausland was machen und dann so gar nicht mehr an grundrechte des grundgesetzes gebunden werden auf den bmw bezogen war genau das die argumentationslinie bis gestern
also da hieß es na ja wieso wie es handeln hier wir sind deutschland und das grundgesetz wirkt nur für deutschland oder für deutsche aber wenn wir eine ausland ausland fernmeldeamt klärung machen dann
dann sehen wir jetzt nicht warum diese menschen rechtsanspruch haben irgendwie grundrechtsschutz zu bekommen
interessanterweise und das ist wirklich fast schon rotest möchte ich sagen wurde wurde argumentiert
würde man diesen menschen grundrechtsschutz gewähren dann wäre das ja grundrechts realismus also man würde ja diesen armen menschen die von b n überwacht werden man das man könnte ja dann den.
Doch keine grundrechte zugehst zu schreiben denn das wäre ja ein eingriff in die souveränität.
Ihre länder und das ist schon phänomenal dass man sagt okay wir können euch überwachen aber ihr könnt euch da nicht gegen wehren weil sonst würden wir euch ja in euren rechten verletzen weil ihr
rechte von uns bekommt solche theorien gab es da und ja die vertreter der bundesregierung haben wirklich.
Dutzende seite dazu geschrieben warum das alles völlig logisch ist ja aber das hat,
karlsruhe und so entschieden der bmw ist auch im ausland an die grundrechte gebunden generell die deutsche staatsgewalt ich will da jetzt nicht ausufern aber das hat auch signalwirkung für andere,
felder stichwort rüstungsexporte zum beispiel stichwort bundeswehreinsätze der auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr ja auch.
Dort überall ist die deutsche staatsgewalt im ausland tätig also ich kann mir vorstellen dass dieses urteil auch für ganz andere
teilgebiet des rechts wo es nicht so sehr um überwachung geht ja signalwirkung hat und das ist.
Bin ich auf euer intro zurückgehen darf das ist ein fast zum feiern ja also das ist schade dass es bis ins jahr zweitausendzwanzig gebraucht hat um so eine banalität festzustellen aber es war eben ja wir haben uns,
solange mit solchen absurden rechtsterroristen umschlagen müssen und die sind jetzt gekippt also egal wo die bundesregierung handelt das grundgesetz gilt für sie und das ist gut.
Grundrechts imperialismus super hier wir stülpen dir die würde über nein ich will nicht.
Ihr lacht aber das steht dann halt so in offiziellen schrift setzen der bundesregierung an verfassungsgericht diese wörter stehen da die benutzt das ist kein slang oder so das ist das wird so das wird so bezeichnet das ist.
Grundrechts realismus wow wow.
Da kann man ja mal die betroffenen länder fragen welchen teil des deutschen imperialismus am wenigsten mögen der wird den grundrechten darum geht's echt zu weit.
Also ihr könnt gerne unsere gesamte bevölkerung bewachen das ist gar kein problem ja aber wenn ihr den jetzt auch noch rechte zuschreibt dass sie sich dagegen wehren können dass das das das geht einfach zu weit das ist kann's nicht sein ja verpisst euch.
Wir sind die exportnationen wenn auch grundrecht.
Ab jetzt geht das auch los ne ja und diese festlegung,
die hat so einige dinge zieht die nach sich ne denn wenn jetzt der bnd auch außerhalb europas an artikel zehn also das kommunikations geheimnis gebunden ist,
dann gelten da halt auch auflagen die sonst für ihn gelten nicht eins zu eins ich kann jetzt nochmal den,
zweiten satz des urteils vorlesen der heißt dann,
der schutz der einzelnen grundrechte kann sich im inland und ausland unterscheiden ja also das ist ein typisches karlsruhe ja aber urteil das heißt hier wird ein grundsatz erstmal aufgestellt ihr seid ein grundrechte gebunden,
kann aber differenziert werden wir können vielleicht gleich darauf eingehen was es dann im einzelnen heißt es wird jetzt aber nicht so sein dass jetzt irgendwie
der bnd bei der massenüberwachung genauso hohe hürden an die überwachung hat wie wenn jetzt in deutschland ein telefonat gezielt abgehört wird von einem deutschen das.
Nicht der fall sein und die aufgabe die das gericht jetzt hatte war eben zu sagen ok wie kann er sich dann unterscheiden also was sind eure grenzen
und was dürft ihr aber trotzdem tun außerhalb europas bei der massenüberwachung.
Und was was was steht da jetzt drin also was was was darf denn jetzt sozusagen überwacht werden also welche daten dürfen dürfen erfasst erhoben.
Werden und wie wie darf man das jetzt wir dürfen die ausgewertet werden.
Also es ist glaube ich wichtig darauf hinzuweisen und das ist finde ich extrem wegweisend
dass karlsruhe festgestellt hat dass,
das was der bmw heute macht im internet mit paket vermittelten in form daten übermittlung dass das nicht mehr zu vergleichen ist mit den methoden der strategischen fernmeldeamt aufklärung die wir ja noch bis vor.
Fünfundzwanzig jahren gekannt haben das letzte große urteil aus karlsruhe zur strategischen,
das wurde neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig gesprochen und da ging es,
um das strategische telekommunikationsüberwachung die tatsächlich noch leitungsgruppe war und.
Jetzt stellt karlsruhe eben fest naja es hat sich halt ein bisschen was getan dieses internet das hat sich durchgesetzt und das setzt sich so hart durch das.
Wenn ihr jetzt massenhaft überwachen könnt dann könnt ihr nicht mehr nur ein paar telefonate die,
personen führen überwachen sondern ihr könnt wenn ihr wollt das gesamte leben von menschen überwachung ja das heißt es dadurch dass das internet allumfassend wird wird eure überwachung im zweifel auch allumfassend und diese kerbe
oder diesen
schlenker mussten sie nehmen um für sich selber argumentieren zu können dass sie sich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz auf die prinzipien aus dem neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig urteil festlegen mussten.
Muss man glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen erklären also die,
was ich genau geändert hat wenn du früher telefone abhören durftest dann hast du irgendwie gespräche gehabt die musste da musste ein mensch die protokollieren die konntest du,
nicht wirklich strukturiert erfassen das heißt man konnte eigentlich,
wenn man die wirkliche kapazität deiner überwachung relativ gut darüber steuern wieviel manpower oder,
du zur verfügung hast ne das muss ja alles nochmal in ein ja ich sage mal in ein menschen lesbarer format,
gebracht werden und bei so einer paket vermittelten überwachung kannst ja unmengen sehr unmengen an strukturierten daten die du automatisiert durchkämmen kannst wo du.
Unglaublich viel daten.
Automatisiert überwachen kannst um am ende das destillat davon das was so viel aufmerksamkeit erfordert dass es nicht mit dem computer selber machen kannst automatisiert machen kannst.
Das lässt er dann am ende noch ein paar menschen machen hast aber eine viel größere,
überwachungs- und verarbeitung ist kapazität weil die daten eben digital sind und dann spiegelt sich darin nicht nur kommunikation wieder sondern eben auch noch
eine ganze reihe anderer menschlicher tätigkeiten die er dann
auch erfasst werden sei es das was du auf facebook liest oder sowas ne so dass dieses dieses ausmaß,
glaube ich auf zwei weisen halt gewachsen ist erstens kommunikation ist jetzt viel mehr als nur ein bisschen telekommunikation und sie kommt aber in einem format was auf sich viel besser für eine für eine auswertung eignet,
da denke ich ist klar dass da dass das,
da hat sich halt die welt wirklich geändert da selbst in deutschland wurde digitalisierung ja mit allen mitteln verhindert wird haben wir dann hier eine veränderung nicht abwenden können.
Absolut das ist ist genau der punkt und das ist ist jetzt nicht,
also es wäre schlimm wenn karlsruhe das nicht anerkannt hätte aber es ist gleichzeitig natürlich auch gut
dass sie es haben um sich juristisch schon ein bisschen ich sag mal frei machen zu können denn sonst sind gerade ist das verfassungsgericht ist ja sehr stark durch eine fahrt abhängigkeit geprägt ja also man man muss schon gute gründe haben warum man,
anders entscheidet als die verfassungsrichter vor zwanzig jahren und die haben sie eben haben sie eben jetzt gefunden aber ja wie du sagst ja also neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig hatte zum beispiel der
das weiß man heute noch nicht wirklich eine automatisierte spracherkennung
für die strategische das mussten wirklich menschen anhören und heute wir kommen dann vielleicht später zu wenn wir über die kooperation mit ausländischen nachrichtendiensten
reden heute
können andere nachrichtendienste in dieses thema live etwas einpflegen was sie für sich selber brauchen das heißt der bnd stellt sozusagen die infrastruktur bereit für andere die dann da selber
maschinen gesteuert,
kommunikation überwachen das sind völlig andere dimension und ja ich glaube vor allen dingen natürlich das smartphone das internet der dinge das.
Kommunikation rückt so nah an uns heran und ist so allumfassend dass einfach unser leben komplett abgebildet werden kann und es wäre fatal gewesen wäre es jetzt gehießen hätte okay der bmw darf
außerhalb europas letztlich quasi dann ja gesamtes das leben von menschen
vierundzwanzig stunden komplett lückenlos überwachen jeden gedanken den man hat ja das aber das schon auf dem spiel und das war war die auffassung war die auffassung der der bundesregierung
ja tim hatte gefragt was was steht drin.
Ich glaube wir könnten mal versuchen also das ding ist lang es liegt jetzt gerade vor mir das sind hunderteinundvierzig seiten.
Liest aber vor.
Ja genau also das ist das ist vielleicht keine ganze doktorarbeit aber zumindest mal drei viertel davon
da steckt natürlich eine menge drin ich muss jetzt auch sagen das war gestern ich habe das jetzt noch nicht komplett gelesen aber wir könnten uns einfach mal vielleicht so an der normalen überwachungsmaßnahmen entlang handeln ja also die gewinnt mit die beginnt mit der frage darf ich überhaupt was überwachen zweitens
was darf ich da mit den daten machen dann,
drittens gibt's da vielleicht noch irgendwie bestimmte dinge worauf ich achten muss also sind ja journalisten drin sind da anwälte drin ist da irgendwie kernbereich schutz also sind da höchst private dinge die mich einfach nichts angehen,
wie wir das geregelt
danach darf ich die daten auch ins ausland geben ja also wenn ich jetzt hier erkenne okay bei kann da gibt's einen anschlag in einem anderen land unter welchen bedingungen darf ich die daten weitergeben.
Der nächste punkt des urteils ist dann.
Unter welchen bedingungen dürfen dienste auch strukturell kooperieren ja also über so ein einzelfall hinaus bmw zum beispiel was dürfen die jetzt als team sozusagen tun und der letzte punkt die kontrolle des ganzen ja also wie ist der
n in seiner arbeit kontrolliert ja das sind so die die sechs themenfelder.
Zu denen sich karlsruhe vertieft geäußert hat.
Dann gehen wir doch mal dem entlang.
Dann gehen wir mal lang ne also ich mache mal hier kurz mal durch das urteil also.
Ich glaube ich glaube der c das gestern auch getwittert bei aller euphorie.
Also vielleicht habe ich gar nicht gesagt weil's offensichtlich ist es gesetzes verfassungswidrig ich glaube wir haben es noch nicht gesagt.
Das wird man dann nochmal sagen dürfen.
Sagen dürfen.
Manche dinge sind so offensichtlich man vergisst es dann gleich schon wieder ne also fast alle punkte die wir angegriffen haben sind in der jetzigen form verfassungswidrig,
und das ist gut so also das ist das ist ein toller sieg da haben wir uns auch wirklich darüber gefreut und auch in einer deutlichkeit sind die verfassungswidrig dass man das als als wirkliche echte schlappe der bundesregierung,
sehen muss.
Und gleichzeitig habe ich eben schon gesagt das ist naja aber entscheidung der fünfte leitsatz ist ein satz und.
Der klingt in meinem ohr nicht ganz so schön der heißt nämlich die strategische auslands kommunikation ist mit artikel zehn absatz eins grundgesetz
klammer auf das ist die
telekommunikationsüberwachung nicht grundsätzlich unvereinbar das heißt und das muss man jetzt auch so feststellen das ist jetzt die erste grundsatzentscheidung von karlsruhe zum thema massenüberwachung im digitalen zeitalter des bnd
und karlsruhe sagt ganz klar ihr könnt das im grundsatz schon machen also massenüberwachung wird nicht mehr verschwinden.
Zumindest nicht auf absehbare zeit und es geht nicht mehr um die frage ob sondern um die frage wie
ich will nicht sagen dass wir uns wirklich erhofft haben dass karlsruhe in gänze kippt das wäre wohl ein bisschen illusorisch gewesen aber jetzt ist es schwarz auf weiß und jetzt geht es eben um die frage.
Ja was sind denn die hürden der der überwachung und hier hat.
Karlsruhe bei der frage der erfassung einerseits im prinzip gesagt ihr müsst.
Alles was ihr im grundsatz da machen wollt und gesetz also irgendwie sektoren steuern und inhalte euch anschauen und metadaten auswerten
und auf leitung zugreifen und auf ganze netze zugreifen das könnt ihr im grundsatz schon machen ihr müsst nur präziser sagen wofür.
Und.
Bisher stehen da halt so gummiparagraphen drin wie handlungsfähigkeit deutschlands und ja dort wird jetzt eben gesagt,
ihr.
Müsst klarer benennen was sind die zwecke der der überwachung geht es darum terrorismusbekämpfung dann hat der bmw relativ
viel spielraum will ich will ich mal sagen dort zu überwachen geht es um.
Eher so politische politische fragen dann müsst ihr müsst ihr ein bisschen müssen müsst ihr präziser werden und dürfen nicht mehr.
In gänze irgendwie komplett ins blau hineinhorchen und mal alles alles anzapfen genau also das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen abstrakt ich glaube die die details,
sind am ende entscheidend wir müssten vielleicht einmal noch kurz erklären,
was sogenannte überwachung ist das ist nämlich das das pendant so ein bisschen es war ja auch bisher schon so dass.
Dass der bundesnachrichtendienst.
Ja alles was irgendwie in deutschland bezug hatte da konnte man sich ja wirklich nicht mehr rausreden dass hier irgendwie das telekommunikations geheimnis von deutschen
betroffen ist das ist im sogenannten artikel gesetz am geregelt das nennt sich dann internationale telekommunikationsüberwachung
und.
Hier gelten schon seit dem neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig urteil relativ starke vorgaben also wenn da deutsche irgendwie mit betroffen sind oder wenn es in deutschland bezug hat dann ist der bmw.
Deutlich deutlich mehr eingeschränkt erinnert euch vielleicht noch dass ich eben gesagt hatte okay wir reden ihr im rahmen der ausland ausland fernwert aufklärung auf hundertvierundfünfzigtausend kommunikationseinheit pro tag,
die sie raus die sie rausziehen sie sagten dann im januar dass sie.
Nach der überwachung in einem halben jahr nur einhundert personen,
überwachen in ungefähr sechshundertfünfzig überwachungsmaßnahmen ja also der der unterschied hundertvierundfünfzigtausend pro tag.
Zu sechshundertfünfzig im halben jahr also das worum es gestern ging ist die deutlich deutlich wichtigere.
Überwachung von ndr rein quantitativ auf auf jeden fall und natürlich die super maximallösungen wäre gewesen wenn karlsruhe gesagt hat na ja dadurch dass auch ausländer im ausland,
grundrechtsschutz haben,
regelt man jetzt einfach alles gleich so ein grundrecht ist irgendwie nicht an deutschland gebunden also ist jetzt irgendwie hat alles in deutschland bezug und das wird aber nicht kommen,
also diese zweiteilung zwischen dem artikel zehn gesetz und dem bmw gesetz
die wird es weitergeben das sagt karlsruhe auch explizit das heißt wir werden wohl ein gesetz haben.
In dem klarer benannt wird okay zu welchen themen darf der npd was machen es muss irgendwie im terror gehen und so weiter und so fort
aber der wird längst nicht so eng an die kette gelegt werden wie bei dem artikel gesetz also das wäre wohl
etwas zu optimistisch dass das zu glauben.
Jetzt war ja auch dieser berufs- träger schutz in dem ganzen ja auch ein besonderes thema so ist ja auch schon gesagt das müssen die richtigen leute klagen und da ist das ja auch ein argument gewesen.
Inwiefern ist denn das berücksichtigt worden.
In der tat also medial muss man sagen hieß es am ende immer journalisten klagen gegen den bmw und das,
ist auch so gewollt gewesen von uns kommunikativ haben wir genau diese karte gespielt das hier journalisten die mit ihren quellen.
Darauf angewiesen sind vertraulich zu sprechen die eben den start kontrollieren soll und wenn sie den staat kontrollieren sollen ist es doof wenn der staat irgendwie mit der leitung hängt das haben wir medial sehr stark gespielt weil es eindringlich war
und das haben wir auch rechtlich stark gespielt man muss aber sagen wir haben in der in der
in der verfassungsbeschwerde rein juristisch beide karten gespielt also wir haben sowohl telekommunikationsgeschäft gespielt als auch pressefreiheit.
Und um das wirklich klarzumachen also hier ist jetzt.
Pathetisch gesprochen ist jetzt für alle menschen auf der welt was was erreicht worden ja also jeder mensch auf der welt kann jetzt theoretisch ein grundrechtseingriffen nach dem grundgesetz geltend machen
wenn er denn mal erfahren würde dass er überwacht wurde das ist wohl eher der haken in der praxis aber,
das ist erreicht worden und zusätzlich und das hat uns als reporter ohne grenzen natürlich schon auch gefreut hat karlsruhe gleichzeitig gesagt dass die das bmw gesetz in der aktuellen form
auch eingriff in die pressefreiheit ist unverhältnismäßig eingriff in die pressefreiheit und auch dort reformiert werden muss
und hier wird's für uns schon spannend jetzt werden denn erstmals wird der bnd jetzt gezwungen sein.
Ich sag mal so eine art qualitatives moment einzubringen in die frage ob er überwachen darf bisher war das sehr stark ja themen getrieben also die mussten irgendwie sah mussten sich.
Hoffe ich dass sie das müssen intern rechtfertigen okay wir wollen jetzt diese telefonnummer als elektro steuern und alle alle kommunikationslösung an die wir so ranzukämpfen können versuchen wir infos zu bekommen
über diese telefonnummer oder wie die email adresse.
Und jetzt wird es so sein und da war karlsruhe eben relativ klar dass karlsruhe gesagt hat na ja ihr müsst auch noch besonders darauf.
Wert legen dass
geschützte berufe wie das sind in deutschland vor allen dingen vier das sind mediziner aufgrund des ärzte geheimnisses geistliche aufgrund des beichtgeheimnis journalistin journalisten,
aufgrund eben quellenschutz und anwältinnen und anwälte ja mandantschaft verhältnis
dass ihr dort auch nicht diese schützgüte die wir in unserer rechtsordnung haben umgeht das war für uns als medienmanipulation ziemlich wichtiges thema beispiel panama papers,
der ja die irgendwie die europäischen dienste zumindest haben irgendwie alle das verbot sich.
Ihre eigenen ihre eigene bevölkerung massenhaft zu überwachen kriegen aber so ein bisschen in freifahrtschein fürs ausland und bei den panama papers haben irgendwie journalisten aus irgendwie hundertdreißig hundertvierzig ländern oder so zusammengearbeitet
und um deutlich zu machen also der den die hätte jetzt die washington post,
komplett durch durchleuchten können ja der hätte einfach als elektroschaltung können jede e-mail adresse die washington post com heißt dass das das greifen wir ab und das werden wir auch aus und das dürfen wir auch auswerten ja dann.
Ist natürlich klar dass zum beispiel bei so einem projekt für den panama-papers.
Wenn sie eine gemeinsame datenbank haben wo die irgendwie ihre recherchen strukturieren und und vorbereiten dass du dann da als bin natürlich auch erfährst was was.
Leute tun die du eigentlich überhaupt nicht überwachen darfst und hier sind jetzt wirklich anforderungen.
Formuliert worden von karlsruhe dass man hier,
erstmals ins gesetz wird schreiben müssen okay ihr müsst bei der massenüberwachung irgendwie darauf achten dass ihr nicht systematisch journalistin journalisten zum beispiel steuert und das ist für uns das ist schon ein riesen erfolg denn es gab 's.
Das gab's bisher noch nie ja also ich weiß noch das waren so eines meiner ersten politischen gespräche.
Das habe ich mit einem unions- abgeordneten geführt damals zweitausendsechzehn und habe ihm gesagt ja sie können auch jetzt hier nicht so ein gesetz machen und einfach da nichts für die pressefreiheit reinschreiben und er guckte mich an und fragte
der guckte mich an wie ein auto und sagte so ich weiß gar nicht wie sie darauf kommen also das war wirklich so
also wirklich so das war so totales unverständnis maximal machen was haben wir denn noch nie gemacht dass wir da jetzt irgendwie uns um
berufs- träger schützen wir einfach gar nicht wie das gehen soll also das ist ja irgendwie nett aber nee sehe ich jetzt echt nicht den zwang und
das ist schon für uns schön dass dort auch nochmal das karlsruhe generell jetzt schon hürden gelegt hat dass der bmw im eu-ausland nicht mehr so einfach überwachen kann
und er hat jetzt auch noch die auflage besonders geschützt berufsgruppen die eben ja für die demokratie auch besonders.
Besonders wichtig sind ja dass er da noch mal mehr schauen muss insgesamt.
Das ist leider so muss man schon zugeben dass sich die frage.
Werde ich überwacht ja oder nein und darf ich überwacht werden ja oder nein zunehmend auf die frage das würde ich das würde ich mal auf so 'ne metaebene heben dieses.
Dieses urteils die verschiebt sich zunehmend von der frage dürfen wir erfassen zur frage dürfen wir es auch auswerten also,
es geht nicht mehr so darum dass prinzipiell irgendwas gar nicht erst erfasst werden darf sondern du kaufst eigentlich das argument okay bei den dimensionen,
ja erfasst es halt erstmal und wenn ihr merkt bei der auswertung oh mist.
Darf ich nicht weil es ist ein deutscher parteiliche darf ich nicht weil grund x dann darf ich es irgendwie nicht verwerten also wir kommen eher zur frage verwertung verbote weil einfach.
So ein bisschen.
Realismus fast schon einkehrt und sagt ok wer massenüberwachung im grundsatz gut heißt der kann jetzt auch nicht so tun als ob es möglich wäre irgendwie.
Bestimmte dinge gar nicht erst zu erfassen denn bei vermittelte kommunikation sagt ihr halt die die adresse nicht,
in vielen fällen vielleicht wo es herkommt aber längst nicht in allen.
Aber gerade bei dieser verwertung da kommt doch dann dieses thema weitergabe und teilen mit rein weil da hattest du doch diese.
Dieses beispiel auch gerade schon genannt das ich glaube bad aibling wurde das groß immer weiter stichwort unter dem das zitiert wurde wurde mich letztendlich die bkn spionage infrastruktur mit.
Selektieren von den von unseren amerikanischen freunden.
Gefüttert wurde und die die ergebnisse auch problemlos zurückbekommen haben und dann die irgendwie die annahme war wie hieß das partyduo dass man sagt.
Wenn die das wollen und dürfen wenn die bei uns gucken da gehört es sich für uns nicht.
Da reinzuschauen was sie interessiert was mit anderen worten letztendlich unsere.
Spionage infrastruktur wird von den amerikanern gegen unsere bürger verwendet und wir können aber nichts dagegen tun weil das gehört sich nicht.
Das ist das ist ein glaube ich nicht kern dieser party will das ist eher wahrscheinlich auf der der ring tausch auf den du anspielst oder fährt party wohl meint zum beispiel im kern das wenn jetzt zwei dienste kooperieren
also die kooperiert mit dem mit dem bmw und der bnd kriegt was von der nsa dann darf der bnd das erstmal nicht weitergeben,
also der darf das nicht an der party weitergeben dazu hat karlsruhe auch was gesagt.
Okay dann habe ich die aber dann dann nehme ich den begriff für party wohl zurückbleibe aber bei der praxis weil das das geht ja so nicht.
Nee geht dir geht so nicht man muss schon sagen karlsruhe hat sich jetzt nicht so dezidiert dazu geäußert,
ob der bnd jetzt irgendwie verhindern muss dass in deutschland massenhaft überwacht wird das steht auch nicht so richtig in deren kompetenzbereich natürlich da können sie sich nicht zu äußern.
Diese kennzeichnungspflicht was du gerade sagtest mit der datenweitergabe das gesetz tatsächlich voll auf dieser verarbeitung ebene an also die,
die nachrichten aus wertheim und auswerten die werden,
so kann ich das nur vermuten immer längere listen haben bekommen jetzt wohl gegen sie prüfen müssen ob sie damit noch bestimmte dinge tun können das,
geht dabei los dass sie irgendwie dann gucken müssen okay es ist hier ein journalist mit seiner quelle ist das irgendwie einen mensch der hier sich seit seinem
arzt anvertraut und über krankheiten spricht ist es eine person die psychische probleme hat und ängste schildert also sind wir zum beispiel einen kernbereich schutz dann wird das irgendwie ausgesondert wenn nicht
und dann werden die wahrscheinlich so eine checkliste haben müssen und da hat karlsruhe jetzt relativ klar gemacht okay ihr dürft zumindest mal nichts weitergeben.
Wo ihr,
naja wissentlich oder wo es wahrscheinlich ist oder wo es überhaupt noch möglich ist dass menschen in ihren ländern dadurch repressalien erfahren wir können auch hier das beispiel bringen ja also,
es kann natürlich sein dass das aufgrund der zentralen lage deutschlands der bmw kommunikation von journalisten.
Erfasst die ihn eigentlich egal sind weil es nicht sein auftragsprozesse ist aber andere ausländische nach dem dienst nahmen an dieser kommunikation riesen interesse.
Und wollen das haben und gehen dann in ihrem land auch vielleicht physisch mit gewalt gegen diese person vor
hier hat karlsruhe gesagt da bleiben sie aber finde ich ein bisschen zu zu sanft da sagen sie der bnd,
müsse sorge dafür tragen dass es hier dass ich an rechtsstaatliche prinzipien gehalten wird bisher läuft es nur so das haben wir auch im januar noch mal detailliert erfahren es wird so eine art absichtserklärung.
Gemacht vor jeder kooperation also.
Das sind so zwei drei seiten wo drin steht okay das sind unsere grundsätze hier im ndr und das sind die grundsätze im grundgesetz und ihr müsst euch daran halten und ansonsten dürft ihr daten die ihr von uns kommt nicht
nicht nutzen oder müsste es bescheid sagen und dann kannst du dich natürlich schon fragen welche diktator sagt ja stimmt also sorry
dass die daten interessieren mich voll aber ich werde den menschen jetzt foltern und deswegen gebe ich die daten wieder zurück das ist so ein bisschen.
Schwierig,
also und dieser da diesen datenaustausch hat karlsruhe war explizit nicht im im grundsatz widersprochen weil sie da schon das argument kaufen der dienste,
du des ja also du musst
lieferbar sein du musst auch was liefern auf dem geheimdienst markt wenn du nicht von anderen abgeschnitten werden willst und dieses argument hat offensichtlich gezogen das hat hat die bundesregierung im januar extrem stark gemacht.
Dass man auf keinen fall eine in eine lage kommen dürfen dass man nichts mehr zu bieten habe auf dem markt.
Da also da würde ich gerne nochmal
das will ich mich gerne noch beton weil das schien mir in der sowohl in der vorberichtserstattung wo ich auch dazu gefragt wurde als auch jetzt in der.
Berichterstattung zum urteil ja sehr übernommen worden zu sein es wird immer gesagt so
boah wenn wir pech haben dann können wir den amis jetzt nichts mehr bieten ja
und wer nichts anzubieten hat kriegt auch nichts und dann geben die amis uns nicht mehr die wertvollen hinweise wie wir die terroranschläge verhindern können ja aus rache aus rache an unseren grundrechten,
lassen die amis uns dann hier demnächst wieder irgendwelche anis amri über den dorfplatz fahren was ja eine völlig also eine dermaßen absurde idee wäre ja dass man sagt so also was ist das denn für ein
befreundeter dienst
wenn er dir wissentlich informationen vorenthält weil er sagt so naja also entschuldigung wenn ihr eure bürger nicht ausspioniert machen wir es halt aber dass dann sagen wir euch das natürlich nicht wenn anschläge bevorstehen völlig absurde argumentation aber
das war wurde eigentlich in der berichterstattung immer wieder betont dass das jetzt dass das große problem sei.
Absolut also da stimme ich dir total zu dass die mediale berichterstattung oder dass das auch die
vertreter der bundesregierung des b immer wieder ja ich würde so sagen die haben ängste geschürt ja die haben immer wieder gesagt wie wichtig diese maßnahme ist total interessant war dass
jeder also ich habe da auch mal einen text zugeschrieben und habe mir einfach diese haben wir mal die fakten angeschaut,
keines der beispiele sie haben halt immer beispiele gebracht wie wie wie wichtig das ist ja irgendwie taliban leute irgendwie verhaftet oder menschenleben gerettet anschläge verhindert
keines der beispiele gebracht haben hatte was mit anlass dieser massenüberwachung zu tun.
Also es ging immer um strategien um gezielte kommunikation kommunikationsverweigerung und karlsruhe hat.
Hat er überhaupt nicht beurteilt es steht überhaupt nicht zur debatte ob ob der bnd gezielt menschen überwachen darf zu klar muss er irgendwie,
jemand überwachen können wenn er wenn er weiß dass da irgendwie menschen anschlagsplan darum geht's gar nicht das wurde aber so inszeniert und es wurde auch absolut übernommen,
die bundesregierung hat sich hier viel ich glaube viel kleiner gemacht als als sie ist und auch der bnd,
egal welche rechtlichen hürden du hast ja die die die zentrale lage am deko die bleibt die er und also vielleicht.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die dass die sagt ja gut okay jetzt.
Habt ihr da irgendwie so ein höchstrichterliches urteil und deswegen lassen wir euch lassen wir euch jetzt links liegen so ja weil du hast ja trotzdem diesen schatz in deinem land und kannst du noch was rausziehen und du nimmst natürlich als dienst glaube ich das was du kriegen kannst
also das überzeugt mir auch nicht aber.
Also ich hab's jetzt hier gerade mal nebenbei ein bisschen rausgesucht hier steht halt also in den leitsätze ist dann im urteil ein bisschen bisschen klarer aber hier steht für den ungarn für den umgang der partnerdirektor mit den übermittelt daten sind gehaltvolle zusagen einzuholen,
ja also.
Hallo.
Ja
Gehaltvolle zu sagen.
Da sind wir wieder wird mir nicht so ganz warm ums herz vor allen dingen wenn man wirklich ja wir rutschen so ein bisschen rein von der datenübersetzung ins ausland zu zu kooperation und das war für mich fast der.
Der erschreckendste teil auch der der mündlichen verhandlung dass da wirklich kooperation bestehen und das haben,
auch die die leute vor gericht so gesagt wo wirklich ausländische nachrichtendienste.
Wirklich automatisiert eigene selektiv also tausende von eigenen sektoren steuern können und der bnd überhaupt nicht mitkriegt.
Was das für die lektoren sind also es wird eine allgemeine absichtserklärung geschlossen wo irgendwie gesagt wird ja haltet euch mal die menschenrechtslage verkürztes jetzt haltet euch mal die menschenrechte und im gegenzug,
können gesagt uns bescheid wenn ihr was findet was für uns auch wichtig ist und hier ist die akp um um eure,
csv fall mit mit den e-mail-adressen und telefonnummern,
einzuspeisen so und ihr kriegt alles einfach geliefert so als rohdaten strom ja es ist wirklich wirklich eine art schnittstelle und wo auch die.
Also da spielt jetzt nicht als zitat wiedergeben weil dafür ist zu lange her aber da haben die wirklich sinngemäß gesagt ja na klar kann der missbrauch,
also natürlich können wir jetzt hier nicht wenn wir mit hunden die kooperieren mit hunderten geheimdiensten in der welt ja natürlich können wir jetzt nicht.
Der bmw kann seine eigenen sektoren nicht mal prüfen.
Weil es einfach zu viele sind ja wir reden über zehn hunderttausende sektoren die wissen selber nicht mal ob sie's ob sie sektoren steuern die sie gar nicht steuern dürfen und natürlich können sie jetzt auch nicht auch überprüfen sagen sie zumindest dass ich es nicht können
was jetzt ausländische nachrichtendienste da noch steuern und das finde ich aus einer demokratischen perspektive hoch problematisch
also du hast da wirklich systeme am laufen wo am ende vielleicht kein einzelner mehr weiß ob das eigentlich erlaubt es
und das system so funktioniert dass alle sich aufeinander verlassen aber gleichzeitig wissen.
Das was schief läuft und das ist schon etwas was was nicht cool ist das ist aber auch nicht im grundsatz gekippt worden.
Jetzt muss man natürlich sagen also in solchen situationen nicht mehr das haben wir ja an anderen ich sag mal dass das bundesverfassungsgericht wird dem.
Einen solchen umstand ja nicht zum ersten mal begegnet sein wo sie sagen aha okay wir geben hier irgendjemanden der macht und stellen fest hoch,
findet missbrauch statt erlaubst was weiß ich erlaubst der polizeigewalt anzuwenden findet auch missbrauch statt erlaubst geheimdiensten zu spionieren findet missbrauch mit statt ne erlaubst leuten was weiß ich steuerprüfung bei anderen zu machen findet missbrauch mit statt.
Die arterien staat ja eigentlich damit umgeht ist dann zu sagen okay dann müssen wir eben diesen missbrauch unter strafe stellen.
Ahnden und natürlich vor allem irgendwie kontrollieren was haben sie denn in in der richtung gemacht.
Genau also kontrolle war auch in der mündlichen verhandlung.
Ich würde fast sagen eines der großen themen also es war nicht das größte thema was er wirklich ein ein ganz zentrales thema.
Ich würde vielleicht kurz einmal sagen wie die kosten
kontrolle bisher außer was kontrolle eigentlich heißt wir haben es in deutschland mit einer extrem fragmentiert geheimdienstkontrolle zu tun fragmentiert heißt wir haben verschiedenste gremien die untereinander wiederum nicht miteinander sprechen dürfen
und dafür.
Die aufgabe tragen bestimmte bereiche der geheimdienste zu kontrollieren wir haben.
Drei zentrale würde ich sagen wir haben einmal das parlamentarische kontrollgremiums das ist das was sicherlich am nächsten am.
Aus der demokratischen perspektive am nächsten am parlament ist am volke ist sozusagen dort sind stellvertretend für die menschen,
sitzen da ich glaube neun neun bis zehn abgeordnete drin die das die das parlament sozusagen abbilden die mehrheitsverhältnissen
und alle paar wochen bis monate berichterstattung bekommen und auch fragen stellen können.
Zweitens hast du die sogenannte kommission die gibts schon ziemlich lange zehn kommission.
Ist auch in anlehnung an dieses artikel zehn gesetz die prüfen.
Eingriffe in artikel zehn vorliegen und wenn ja ob die gerechtfertigt sind die zahlen kommission ist für alle geheimdienste tätig nicht nur für ein,
weil er zum beispiel das verfassungsschutz auch telekommunikationsüberwachung machen darf und die zehn kommission.
Besteht aus dem.
Wenigen menschen die größten teils ehrenamtlich diese sache machen und neu geschaffen mit dem unabhängigen mit dem gesetz wurde das,
unabhängige kontrollgremium so heißt das also man hat mit dem gesetz eine weitere kontrollinstanz geschaffen,
der offizielle grund war naja die ausland ausland fernmeldeamt klärung betrifft ja gar nicht artikel zehn die menschen haben ja gar kein anrecht auf artikel zehn,
deswegen können wir das auch nicht da der kommission zuordnen also brauchen wir ein neues kontrollgremium die inoffizielle grund wird sicherlich gewesen gewesen sein je mehr menschen du hast die nur für sich kontrollieren aber nicht miteinander sprechen dürfen desto einfacher ist es natürlich auch,
dort.
Bestimmte dinge systematisch nicht sagen zu müssen das ist meine persönliche meinung aber ich sehe zumindest die gefahr dass es so ist wenn man zu ausgestaltet und.
Hier hat karlsruhe ziemlich klare vorgaben gemacht dass sie gesagt haben so jetzt machen wir einen strich drunter
und ihr habt das bmw gesetzt so wie es jetzt ist es verfassungswidrig aber im grundsatz geht das schon das muss man alles ein bisschen klarer werden es muss alles ein bisschen mehr reduziert werden aber im grundsatz geht das schon dafür muss aber die kontrolle wachsen ja so wie eure volumina gewachsen sind kann es nicht sein dass es ein unabhängiges kontrollgremium da sitzen,
ich glaube zwei richter und richterinnen drin und ein also die sind zu dritt auf jeden fall.
Energie kommission sind sie auch zu dritt oder zu viert glaube ich ja also oder wir haben's ich sag mal so mit mit dem pkw haben wir.
Da gibt's noch einen ständigen bevollmächtigten seit ein paar jahren der hat noch ein bisschen mitarbeiter ich würde mal schätzen die gesamte geheimnis kontrolle hat.
Vermutlich in deutschland keine einhundert personen und allein der bnd hat meines wissens zur sechseinhalbtausend mitarbeiter im moment.
Und dann musste ja noch dazu sehen wie das diese leute die werden ja auch sagen wir mal im weitesten sinne strategisch besetzt ne also ich hatte ja gerade schon erwähnt dass ich da in der vorberichtserstattung mal
zu gefragt wurde und habe ich mir den beitrag auch angeschaut das waren tagesthemen beitrag und dann war da armin schuster.
Ich weiß nicht ist ja nicht sogar der vorsitzende des kontrollgremiums.
Da der ist der vorsitzende des parlamentarischen kontrollgremium ist wenn ich das richtig weiß ehemaliger polizist und cdu-abgeordneter ja.
Kommt aus der außer der der sicherheitskarte schule so ne und,
der hat sich da aber wirklich die ärmel hochgekrempelt und gas gegeben als stünde sein persönlicher ruf auf dem spiel ja.
Denkst sagte wir haben in all den jahren nie irgendetwas festgestellt dass es hier alles wunderbar ne und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Solche leute möchte ich nicht in der in dem kontrollgremium haben wenn man also kontrolleure müssen penible.
Gemeine waden beißer sein nicht welche die sich dann auch noch bei der ersten gelegenheit vor das kontroll.
Stellen und und und sich da auch noch irgendwie wehement vorstellen und das verteidigen das muss einfach jemand sein der sagt ich habe immer noch nichts gefunden das kann doch gar nicht sein nicht nur jemand der sagt auch bei den pkk sitzung gibt's echt immer super schnittchen und die leute,
vom band hier die sind echt nett muss man wirklich sagen die haben echt sind die immer ziemlich nett zu uns da muss man wirklich.
Kann mir auch gar nicht vorstellen dass ich da so viel geändert hat weil was frühere mitglieder.
Solcher gremien berichten ist ja auch genau das dass sie sagen die meisten sachen haben wir nachher aus der presse erfahren.
Also da da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass also wenn man eine wirksame kontrolle haben möchte
sagen wir eine wie war diese schöne formulierung eine gehaltvolle kontrolle ja wenn man eine gehaltvolle kontrolle haben möchte dann muss man die eben auch mit leuten besetzen die motiviert sind was zu finden.
Absolut also
das problem gerade die kommission du hast natürlich immer so ein bisschen das das das wurde auch da im januar deutlich ja wenn dann die die richterin und richter fragen ja hier lieber kontrolleur
wie läuft das dann alles so ja wenn der jetzt sagen würde das ist alles völlig er scheiß und das ist alles voll verfassungswidrig dann würde der ja sagen und ich mache gerade mein arbeit nicht weil das ist meine aufgabe das zu verhindern
und dann bist du noch in so einem absoluten geheimdienst bereich wo jede.
Jede kleinigkeit könnte die könnte gleich die staatssicherheit gefährden das heißt es ist absolut
unmöglich irgendwie öffentlich darüber zu diskutieren das heißt auch die kontrolleure sind ja null rechenschafts pflichtig ja ich will ihnen überhaupt nichts böses unterstellen damit jetzt aber
es findet einfach kein diskurs über ihre arbeit statt weil er nicht system immer nennt sozusagen gar nicht gar nicht stattfinden kann es gab da in der ich glaube das war das kann man so sagen das war das highlight der verhandlung wie.
Eine frau die hieß glaube ich frau cerena trotz verena war richterin also strafrichterin.
Und sie war also dass dieses unabhängige kontrollgremien welches die außen und fernmeldeamt klärung jetzt dann kontrollieren sollte dass da sind zwei,
richter drin und sie wurde dann da eben.
Einberufen und hatte das dann eben zu tun so und.
Da hatte sie sehr offen in dieser verhandlung und einfach auch sehr ich will fast schon sagen sehr menschlich.
Einfach erzählt wie das so war und dass sie so gesagt hat so da,
prallten zwei zwei kulturen aufeinander ja und du das was du gerade sagtest linus irgendwie da müssen dann müssen waden beißer hin ich will jetzt frau frau zerrädert nicht unterstellen dass sie gerne in baden reinbeißt aber,
sie hat einfach,
sie hat einfach einen anderen habitus ja sie ist richterin sie will sachen erfahren ja sie sie fragt nach und da hatte sie erzählt das war man offensichtlich nicht.
Gewohnt und dann gab's irgendwie briefe vom vom bmw so nach dem motto so an an die behördenleitung und zusammen so also was kann das nicht alles ein bisschen.
Hier laufen und kümmern können wir ein bisschen freundlicher miteinander sein so und da hat sie irgendwie gesagt so dass das erstmal irgendwie so ein kulturwandel war dass sie da irgendwie ein bisschen kritischer kritischer nachgefragt hat.
Was hat karlsruhe da jetzt entschieden sie haben auf jeden fall gesagt dass die,
dass die parlamentarische kontrolle
deutlich gestärkt werden muss sie haben gesagt sie muss personell ausgebaut werden die brauchen die brauchen ausreichendes budget sie haben auch den datenschutzbeauftragten in seiner rolle,
was ich ziemlich interessant finde das ist nur in einem satz angesprochen aber auch das ist eine neue form es wird gesagt naja.
Wir würden uns auch mal gerne dadurch dass wir alles automatisiert bei euch wir würden auch gerne mal eure systeme öffnen und euch uns mal eure richter spreche spricht man dann von algorithmen also es wird einfach.
Kann man versuchen dass ihr nebenbei ein bisschen zu finden also es wird darauf angespielt naja wenn ihr alles automatisiert oder irgendwie
eure menschen in den diensten nur noch das vorfinden was maschinen irgendwie in sieben arbeitsprozessen ausgesiebt haben dann wäre es doch auch irgendwie sinnvoll wenn wir gucken ob eure maschinen nicht irgendein bayers haben
also hier steht jetzt im urteil zu regeln ist gegebenenfalls auch der einsatz von algorithmen insbesondere die sicherstellung ihrer grundsätzlichen nachvollziehbar,
nachvollziehbar im hinblick auf eine unabhängige kontrolle das ist ziemlich schwach aber das sind zumindest so dinge,
wo karlsruhe zumindest sich vermutlich auch für später rechtsprechung anknüpfungspunkte geschaffen hat dass man später sagen
explizit sagen kann hey nein es braucht jetzt hier eine eine wirklich technische prüfung der systeme dann auch hier gab es im januar in der verhandlung berichtet dass gesagt wurde
dürfte nicht dieses thema prüfen weil das ist ja und das geht euch nichts an ich glaube das prägende wort in dem bereich kontrolle ist gerichtsälen.
Also sie haben immer wieder gesagt es braucht eine gerichtsälen kontrolle,
und das ist glaube ich gut und ich finde man kann so ein bisschen sagen dass karlsruhe sich offensichtlich vorstellt
dass der bnd ein eigener staat im staat werden soll jetzt gibt's wahrscheinlich manche die sagen,
das ist ja doch immer schon und ein geheimnis ist immer ein start im staat.
Ich würde sagen bisher ist der bmw vor allen dingen der zweite exekutive im staat es ist vor allen dingen ein verlängerter arm der regierung gewesen und also was grundsätzlich anerkannt wird ist das,
kontrolle geheim bleibt also wir werden wir als öffentlichkeit werden denke ich.
Nicht mehr erfahren in zukunft über die arbeit des bmw das muss man leider sagen gefordert wird aber eben das sozusagen.
Eine gerichts- kontrolle die auch dann greift noch mal den punkt wadenbein auf ja die die wirklich auch so eine,
eine art fremdkörper ist und die nicht einfach nur bisher konsum kontrolliert sich die exekutive in aller regel selbst beim bnd ja also das ist das kanzleramt irgendwie als fachaufsicht und guckt ob alles okay läuft aber
das ist halt keine unabhängige kontrolle genau was ich.
Sehr problematisch finde was karlsruhe entschieden hat und da gab es auch ein mitglied des pkw was gestern da war was das auch nicht so cool fand ist dass der spin des bnd
doch gekauft wurde dass man den parlamentarischen kontrollgremium nicht mehr so viel erzählen darf weil die abgeordneten die reden ja alle.
Und im urteil steht tatsächlich so sinngemäß drin na ja so eine richtige geheimhaltung kann man tatsächlich nicht nicht durchsetzen beim parlamentarischen kontrollgremium von daher die muss es schon geben weil es demokratie theoretisch ja wichtig aber,
es ist okay sozusagen eine abschwächung.
Vorzunehmen und das finde ich sehr gefährlich weil wenn wir uns angucken wie in den usa,
sich diese quasi quasi geheim gerichte etabliert haben dass sie einfach auch alles durchgewunken haben das finde ich das stört mich somit am meisten an diesem urteil das irgendwie.
Das demokratische aller kontrollorgan ich will nicht sagen es wurde geschwächt
aber es wurde nicht einbezogen in das neue netzwerk was gefordert wird es wird auch gefordert dass die kontrolle organe untereinander
wenn sie noch fragmentiert sind aber miteinander reden dürfen also wir müssen uns klarmachen bisher durfte das unabhängige gremium nicht mit der kommission reden das war dann wirklich verboten die durften darüber nicht reden die hätten sie strafbar gemacht hier wird jetzt gesagt okay das kann nicht sein ja also das,
nicht dass ihr irgendwie hier so taschenspielertrick macht aber es wird gesagt mit dem parlamentarischen kontrollgremium.
Die kann man so ein bisschen abschneiden und das ist das gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Wird es dann durch irgendwas anderes ersetzt also was ist jetzt die konsequenz daraus was was für eine kontrolle was für ein kontrollrat stellt sich das
gericht jetzt vor also was was liest du aus diesem urteil wie eine künftige konstellation sein könnte und gibt's da irgendwelche fortschritte.
Also man muss sagen dass karlsruhe hier sehr konkret geworden ist.
Eigentlich dürfen sie gar nicht so konkret werden so weil sie sagen auch eigentlich an vielen punkten das ist sache des gesetzgebers
denn das grundgesetz fordert vermutlich eher nur dass es eine kontrolle geben muss und so ein paar leitlinien aber
das jetzt karlsruhe da reinschreibt ok es braucht irgendwie angemessenes budget und so und so und das kontrolliert und dann haben sie halt eine stelle noch reingeschrieben sowie die briten das machen könnte das auch gut sein das ist schon sehr konkret so
und karlsruhe muss ja eigentlich eher prüfen ob gesetze verfassungskonform sind und dann vielleicht so ein paar prints allgemeine prinzipien entwickeln deswegen
ja hat sich karlsruhe hier eigentlich vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen zu weit aus dem fenster gelehnt und ich glaube um.
Auf deine frage zurückzukommen ich glaube dass ich an der kontrolle tour wahrscheinlich nichts ändern wird also.
Mit mit architektur meine ich dass wir das pkgr haben dass wir die kommission haben und dass wir das unabhängige gremium haben ich kann mir nicht vorstellen.
Dass die bundesregierung.
Das unabhängige gremium abschaffen wird sie wollen vermutlich die ausland ausland fernmeldeamt aufklärung so.
Weiterhin behandeln dass sie sagen okay dann ist jetzt halt artikel zehn hier berührt und wir müssen ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein aber es ist schon immer noch was anderes als wenn wir einen klaren deutschen bezug haben und diese hintertür lässt ihn karlsruhe und
die bundesregierung wird sie wird sie nehmen definitiv da bin ich mir sicher und in dieser und wenn du diese logik weiterverfolgst ja dass du sagst okay es gibt einen unterschied zwischen.
Deutschland bezogenen telekommunikationsüberwachung und der die wirklich völlig im ausland stattfindet dann ergibt dieses diese kontrolle.
Ich will nicht sagen dass sie ergibt sinn aber man kann es machen und das werden sie dann weiter tun das heißt ich denke wir werden wahrscheinlich mehr mitarbeiter bekommen wir werden vielleicht auch eine stärkung des datenschutzbeauftragten sehen was die technische prüfung angeht.
Und wir werden wahrscheinlich ein parlamentarische kontrollgremiums erleben was nochmal mehr mitarbeiter bekommt.
Was aber nicht stärker institutionell eingebunden wird in die kontrolle und.
Kann darauf hinausläuft die frage wird sein wie sie dieses gerichtsälen.
Wahrnehmen wollen also was ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Das ist aber jetzt eher eine eigene idee was ich für sinnvoll hielte ist man dass man durchaus sowas wie menschen dort installiert also dass du dass da leute sind keine ahnung ich,
greif jetzt nochmal ich kann halt am besten über pressefreiheit wird sprechen ich greife mir nochmal raus irgendwie gut der bmw hat jetzt die aufgabe irgendwie darauf zu achten,
kein journalisten überwacht werden und dann hat natürlich auch automatisch das kontrollorgan auch die aufgabe ob der systematisch redaktion abgehorcht werden oder nicht und ich glaube.
Was es bräuchte wäre menschen die auch durch ihre vita.
Also durch irgendwie das was ich mitbringen auch an überzeugung
dass sie teile von solchen kontrollorgan werden und einfach dann intern diese perspektive einbringen dass sie sagen okay ich interessiere mich jetzt einfach dafür es ist mein job mich dafür instrument
zu interessieren ob beim bnd systematisch journalisten überwacht werden und gleichzeitig kann es dann teams geben die sich vielleicht um den kernbereich schutz kümmern die einfach,
start besondere expertise haben ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es in so eine richtung ginge das wäre zumindest eine lösung die ich.
Gut fände im rahmen des urteils ja aber das ist muss man schon sagen dass es.
Aufgabe des gesetzgebers das sagt karlsruhe auch sehr klar also wir können jetzt aus dem urteil nicht herauslesen dass es auf jeden fall so sein muss wie die kontrolle aussieht so das wäre auch ein bisschen zu weit gehen.
Ja was folgt denn jetzt daraus aus all dem jetzt muss ja im prinzip die bundesregierung,
handeln jetzt muss ja irgendwas geschehen jetzt müssen dinge sicher ändern das ist einmal,
komplett moniert worden so geht's nicht so und so das sind unsere vorstellungen leitlinien rahmenbedingungen und grundsatzentscheidungen dazu bis wann muss denn jetzt hier eine reaktion erfolgen.
Die muss spätestens erfolgt sein am einunddreißigsten dezember zwotausendeinundzwanzig also karlsruhe hat gesagt das gesetz ist verfassungswidrig.
Aber ihr habt zeit bis ende zweitausendeinundzwanzig um das zu überarbeiten und solange kann das verfassungswidrige gesetz in kraft bleiben das ist relativ normal.
Und dadurch dass wenn ich mich nicht völlig vertue nächstes jahr die nächste.
Vierundzwanzigster oktober an ist es ja.
Okay genau also dann können wir uns sicher sein dass ich vermute mal dann beginnt ja im frühjahr irgendwann der heiße die heiße phase des wahlkampfs da kann ich mir.
Sehr gut vorstellen dass wir ende diesen jahres anfang nächsten jahres neues bundesgesetz haben denn die meine wir ändern es doch letztes jahr wie lange das gedauert hat ja lieber wie war's von herrn lindner lieber.
Gar nicht regieren als falsch regieren und so also das kann sich ja mal ziehen mit so einer regierungsbildung.
Und gerade die union wird es ja nicht zulassen dass der bnd keine gesetzesgrundlage mehr hat für die ausland ausland fernmeldeamt klärung,
von daher werden die das haben sie gestern helge braun der kanzleramt zumindest auch schon gesagt die werden das jetzt zügig umsetzen.
Was ich also zwei dinge.
Steht eigentlich noch spannend ich glaube die werden das zusammenmischen mit anderen projekten die sie auch vorhaben stichwort hack back.
Stichwort online durchsuchung wir erinnern uns an den von andre meister gelegten entwurf kommentierung des verfassungsschutzgesetz es das ist,
schon über ein jahr her dass andere den gelegt hatte und seitdem ist nichts mehr passiert.
Und da steht zwar harmonisierung des verfassungsschutz rechts drüber dort waren aber auch so dinge drin wie der bnd muss hacken dürfen also online durchsuchung und quellen ticket.
Und die sollten auch ins gesetz geschrieben werden und,
ich erkläre mir das so dass da nichts gekommen ist das nämlich dann letzten sommer wurde wurden alle unsere stellungnahmen weiterhin an die bundesregierung zugestellt und dann haben wir auch die geahnt okay ich glaube wir glauben karlsruhe wird hier was
wird dir was urteilen und dann lassen wir das mal kurz noch mit unserem verfassungsschutz recht und mit unseren mit unserem hacking für die.
Für den bnd denn wenn wir das ding eh nochmal aufmachen müssen nach dem karlsruher urteil dann packen wir alles rein also ich glaube wir werden einen riesiges paket kriegen.
Im laufe der nächsten monate wahrscheinlich und was ich dort spannend finde ist das karlsruhe.
Deswegen auch das stichwort hack back karlsruhe ins urteil relativ häufig.
Wenn sie der bundesregierung hintertürchen gelassen hat im sinne von sony ihr könnt es schon so machen muss nur irgendwie passt ein bisschen auf.
Wurde relativ häufig das argument gezückt naja der bnd ist ja nicht operativ tätig.
Also die hören ja nur mit das geht so weit dass sie ich komme noch einmal versprochen letztes mal mit meinem journalistenschule die sagen.
In den rand nummern wo es wo es um die pressefreiheit geht sagen sie nee nee es braucht jetzt hier irgendwie gerichts kontrolle damit geguckt wird okay wer nationalisten systematisch überwacht darf man die auswerten so und dann kommt so.
Blue so eine nummer wo sagt so naja und ihr könnt aber auch von diesem gesamten pressefreiheit schutz absehen.
Wenn es nur darum geht die bundesregierung politisch zu informieren.
Und da denkt man sich so ich dachte das sei ohnehin die aufgabe des bmw gewesen also.
Ich lese das mal ist nicht viel ich lese das mal ganz kurz vor sofern überwachungsmaßnahmen unabhängig von einem sie rechtfertigen in den zweck der gefahren früherkennung ausschließlich dazu bestimmt.
Und darauf ausgerichtet sind der politischen informationen der bundesregierung zu dienen und eine übermittlung der erkenntnisse an andere stellen prinzipiell ausgeschlossen ist.
Kann auf den schutz von vertraulichkeit beziehung verzichtet werden soweit dies erforderlich ist und die ähnliche argumentation findet sich auch an anderen stellen das heißt.
Karlsruhe sagt sobald es solange als wenn es hier nur um informations.
Sammlung geht für die bundesregierung und irgendwie die informationen die daraus gezogen werden aus einer tv.
Dass da irgendwie der name egal ist und der weggelassen werden kann in der meldung dann seid ihr da freier.
Und dann seid ihr da vor allen dingen sehr frei wenn ihr irgendwo anders auf der welt überwacht weil da habt ihr ja keine exekutive müsse und.
Ich finde das argument hochproblematisch ich weiß nicht was ihr darüber denkt ich musste aber als es gelesen habe sofort an den hack back denken.
Weil immer gesagt wird der bnd ist ja keine operative behörde.
Ja damit wird eben gerechtfertigt da hätte ich das schwingt so ein bisschen mit die lesen ja nur mit und die bundesregierung braucht ja infos und solange da keinen schaden raus entsteht.
Kann man da auch mal fünfe gerade sein lassen das finde ich problematisch,
und das finde ich aber auch wichtig daran zu erinnern wenn zum beispiel dann in dieses gesetz und das wird kommen
dass sie das dass sie da rein reinschreiben werden okay ins neue gesetz kommt jetzt auch die ermächtigung dass der online-durchsuchung machen darf so,
und ich finde das eine sehr operative tätigkeit wenn jemand.
Völlig wohl meinen.
Ja wenn ich jemand da sich doch wahrscheinlich mühe geben muss das neueste iphone auf zu knacken ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das so mit zwei klicks geht.
Ja also das ist.
Das ist etwas was glaube ich droht das zweite was ich noch spannend finde auch so ein bisschen die zukunft geblickt und da bin ich auch ein bisschen enttäuscht vom urteil ist der punkt maschine maschine kommunikation
und ich bin da vor allen dingen darüber enttäuscht dass karls oder nichts zugesagt hat weil es offensichtlich eine praxis gibt in diese selber eingeräumt haben
dass sie maschine maschine kommunikation doch sehr bewusst nutzen.
Was heißt denn das jetzt.
Maschine maschine.
Also was was meint das genau maschine maschine kommunikation.
Das ist ich weiß nicht vielleicht kann es linus einmal erst technisch machen dann kann ich nachher sagen was der bmw darunter fast.
Was der bnd darunter versteht hattest du ja glaube ich schon gesagt dass sie sich sogar gar soweit herausgelassen haben dass sie sagen mobilfunk,
telefon kommuniziert mit einer mobilfunk zelle aber maschine maschine na ja dann dann,
im prinzip weitesten sinne das was wir jetzt als internet of things dann auch tatsächlich im internet sehr viel sieht,
oder ein auto fährt irgendwie durch die gegend und sendet irgendwelche daten irgendwohin da wo,
nicht unmittelbar ein kommunikationsvorlagen der durch einen menschen ausgelöst oder durch einen menschen empfangen wird stattfindet was eben im großen maße im zur steuerung von
unterschiedlichen geräten und funktionalitäten genutzt wird.
Ganz genau ja so hätte ich's auch hätte ich's auch gedacht und der bnd.
Das war nicht so ganz klar also da hatte sich in der verhandlung im januar ein mitarbeiter hart versprochen offensichtlich was man immer also ich saß hinten in der verhandlung was man immer daran sah wenn jemand was sagte was ja offensichtlich entweder nicht sagen sollte oder
was zumindest irgendwie grenzwertig war dass alle mitarbeiter der bundesregierung sich immer nach hinten umgeguckt haben immer so was ist denn jetzt passiert
und bei dieser maschine maschine kommunikation gab es dann nämlich die interessante argumentation ja.
Maschine maschine kommunikation ist ja jetzt sind ja maschinen und maschinen sind ja nun wirklich nicht vom grundgesetz.
Gedeckt und das klang hart nach weltraum theorie zwei punkt null,
und dann hatten die richter noch zwei drei mal nachgefragt na ja was ist denn für sie jetzt eine maschine maschine kommunikation dann hatten sie so hatten sie immer.
Beispiele hingeworfen haben sie immer gesagt nein das nicht,
nein das auch nicht aber sie haben nie gesagt was sie eigentlich jetzt als maschine maschine kommunikation machen denn in dem beispiel was ihr mitarbeiter genannt hatte war es nämlich tatsächlich naja wenn sich das handy in die funkzelle einwählen
dann fehlt sich ein handy zu in ein ein ein masten an
und da war also okay dann würde ich mich fragen was ist dann keine maschine maschine kommunikation mehr wenn man das so auslegt hierzu sagt karlsruhe leider gar nichts im urteil.
Und das finde ich sehr sehr problematisch weil
offensichtlich die kreativität im dienst keine grenzen kennt und ich hätte mir irgendwie gewünscht okay wenn sie sich da schon halb versprechen in der verhandlung und sagen naja maschine maschine bewerten wir irgendwie anders,
hätte vielleicht übersehe ist jetzt auch ich habe mir das urteil noch nicht komplett gelesen aber ich habe mal zumindest nach maschine gesucht und in der stellungnahme der bundesregierung wird es wird es erwähnt am anfang.
Des urteils aber es taucht das wort maschine taucht nicht mehr auf von daher fürchte ich.
Dass da jetzt nichts drin steht und das ja das ist schade.
Könnte das bedeuten dass sie sagen wir fressen den ganzen kram nicht das ist einfach kommunikation.
Meinst du jetzt karlsruhe die bundesregierung.
Karlsruhe ne weil du müsstest ja eigentlich erwarten also das problem bei der maschine,
maschine kommunikation ist ja dass es eine ganze reihe und dieses beispiel handy wird sich in funkmast ein ist ja.
Wahrscheinlich unbeabsichtigt ein sehr besonders schönes weil ja das ist ein kommunikationsvorlagen der den du als mensch
überhaupt nicht getriggert hast der wirklich zwischen maschinen stattfindet und für die funktionalität dieser maschinenausfallrisiken lebend ist
der aber nun mal leider gerade deine deinen ort verrät der also quasi zur zu einem location tracking geeignet ist und.
Das wird ja bei immer mehr maschine maschine kommunikation der fall dann eben sein dass sie.
Vielleicht nicht gerade ein brief an deine großmutter ist aber sehr viel aussage über dein.
Verhalten oder über dein leben trifft.
Ja absolut ich stimme dir völlig zu also.
Ich hätte auch erwartet dass maschine maschine wenn dann überhaupt sowas ist wie mein team mein mein smart smartes thermometer funk die temperaturdaten an die cloud.
Und klar das sind halt irgendwie vielleicht zwei maschinen wobei die cloud ist gar kein gerät funktioniert.
Aber das das tut das thermometer ja auch in deinem auftrag also das ist das wirklich zu.
Genau das und ja und vor allen dingen es geht ja darum es bildet ja etwas da sind wir wieder beim anfang ja um dieses allumfassende ja also ist auch.
Und wenn wenn sich die wenn sie die temperatur irgendwie erhöht weil du im winter nach hause kommst und die heizung an machst so dann gibt es ja einfach rückschlüsse darauf ja also man kann davon ausgehen dass wenn jemand ein thermometer hochstellt.
Dass man dann zu hause ist er und also dort anzunehmen dass.
Dass das keine menschliche kommunikation sei das finde ich erstens absurd und wenn wenn also linus ich ich glaube auch dass karlsruhe sagt nee es ist ja klar dass das irgendwie jetzt.
Trotzdem irgendwie grundrechts gebunden ist aber und deswegen vielleicht nichts dazu gesagt hat aber ich meine,
die andere frage ist halt ob der bmw das auch so auslegt also wir können immer nur an die welt rumtheorie ändern wahrscheinlich hat auch karlsruhe nie gesagt naja ist ja klar dass irgendwie ein satellit jetzt im weltraum ist und das ist da auch irgendwie an was gebunden seid aber.
Es brauchte halt offensichtlich jetzt diesen richterspruch dass auch so eine weltraum theorie endlich mal in sich zusammenfällt genauso wie die funktionsträgern theorie also das war so ein bisschen mein punkt wo ich sage so ok wenn sie es euch irgendwie auf dem silbertablett.
Servieren in der mündlichen verhandlung dass das offensichtlich gerade ein weg ist den sie den sie gehen das haben sie gesagt sie haben gesagt maschine maschine machen wir und ist aber für uns an die grundrechte gebunden so.
Da hätte ich mir irgendwie gedacht okay wofür ist eine mündliche also weil.
Ich spreche jetzt natürlich auch so nach vier jahren ja es wurden ich habe das mal nachgezählt es wurde halt über tausend seiten schriftsätze ausgetauscht ja
und also es war halt vieles schon klar so und dann frage ich mich okay wofür ist eigentlich eine mündliche verhandlung da wenn dann da mal so was rauskommt das dazu dann nichts im urteil steht ja das fand ich ein bisschen.
Bisschen schade na ja.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht mal ein fazit nochmal kurz von dir einholen so also,
was fühlst du jetzt so was ist gut und was ist weniger gut was was was sind jetzt so die kernpunkte die jetzt jeder mitnehmen sollte.
Ja man neigt ja jetzt schon wieder jetzt haben wir schon wieder leicht schlechte laune ne.
Hier mal die high einfordern.
Ja man neigt ja also ich sage mal so gestern um zehn uhr fünfzehn war ich richtig happy
also für das urteil gesprochen und wenn du halt dann so vom höchsten deutschen gericht hörst und vier jahre dagegen gekämpft hast dass das also gegen offensichtlich kalten gekämpft hast.
Dann fühlte sich das schon gut an es hat sich auch auf jeden fall natürlich gelohnt und wir haben hier ein urteil aus karlsruhe und das,
muss man ja auch erstmal stehen lassen gesetz in der jetzigen form ist verfassungswidrig punkt,
der npd verstößt gerade gegen unsere verfassung im auftrag der bundesregierung und ich würde sagen das machen sie auch wissentlich
alle wussten dass das eigentlich nicht geht aber sie haben's trotzdem gemacht und dass das festgestellt wurde ist ein erfolg
und ich würde es vielleicht mal als fazit so formulieren dieses urteil ist längst kein sieg aber es ist eine chance.
Das schlimmste abzumildern wir müssen jetzt.
Spätestens jetzt müssen wir sagen okay massenüberwachung des bnd wird nicht mehr verschwinden so die ist jetzt auch im internetzeitalter auch wenn sie in der dimension nochmal richtig stark angewachsen ist.
Ist sie nach meinung von karlsruhe trotzdem noch irgendwie hinzubiegen dass sie mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar ist nochmal das können wir guter schlecht finden ist jetzt so.
Und ich glaube wir dürfen es ist kein sieg für die grundrechte aber es ist eine chance sie vernünftig auszugestalten und das fazit ist dann fast schon ausblick ich glaube.
Wir müssen jetzt vor allen dingen auch fix sein denn die bundesregierung wird auch schnell sein und wird hier neuen aufschlag geben,
wir sollten uns nicht zu lange freuen denn da wird wieder was kommen und die werden natürlich vor allen dingen die abkürzung die
karlsruhe hier eingebaut hat die man nehmen kann die wird die bundesregierung natürlich nutzen und ja ich glaube da
wird jetzt darum gehen irgendwie wiederum in den politischen diskurs einzutreten und das beste daraus zu machen was anderes bleibt uns ja nicht über.
Na super jetzt haben wir jetzt unsere grundstimmung wiederhergestellt ne.
Ist da auch ganz gut ich hatte das gefühl ihr habt euch auch nicht so richtig wohl gefühlt oder also.
Das war mir schon ein bisschen zu euphorisch alles ne.
Aber das heißt ja also das heißt unterm strich um das nochmal noch kürzer zusammenzufassen ist es bleibt das was man häufig mit dem bundesverfassungsgericht urteilen hat es.
Es wird erstmal vielleicht auch absichtlich über die grenzen des grundgesetzes hinaus gezielt um sich dann.
Zumindest die engen grenzen von karlsruhe stecken zu lassen.
Um sicher zu gehen dass man auch wirklich an der grenze operiert ja nicht dass man dann nachher noch irgendwelchen
freiraum gehabt hätte den man hätte ausnutzen können also schreibst du erstmal halt ein fettes einmal alles gesetz und guckst dann was lässt es dann
karlsruhe fixen und machst dann quasi deine definition im zweiten anlauf soll dass sie darauf passen das kennen wir von anderen.
Überwachungs- gesetzen auch und es scheint fast so ein bisschen so zu sein als würde die bundesregierung.
In diesen fragen karlsruhe echt hat so eine art ja qualitätssicherung sehen ne mach so achtzig zwanzig regeln.
Wir machen erstmal,
hundert prozent hundert prozent in der hälfte der zeit dann kloppen die uns ein bisschen was weg und dann bleiben wir mit den dank so können wir sicherstellen ne katze schuldigung so eine art,
zweihundert prozent regel wir machen mal zweihundert prozent und die qualitätssicherung wird auf wirtschaft sein schon auf hundert prozent runter bügeln und wir brauchen uns um hundert prozent zu erreichen musst du halt zweihundert prozent geben ja.
Ich teile deine meinung total.
Zwei ganz letzte eindrücke aus den vier jahren das erste war ganz am anfang der da war ich halt.
Neu sage ich jetzt mal so in diesem ganzen politik kram und zeug und hat dann hatten wir halt auch politische gespräche und dann war so eines meiner ersten gespräche mit einem abgeordneten.
Und der sagte das genau es war ein vertraulichen hintergrundgespräch und er war in regierungsverantwortung der hatte dieses gesetz mitgeschrieben und mit verantwortet
auch öffentlich und er sagte jannik klar gehen wir hier an die grenze und wenn man auf der grenze geht dann,
tritt man auch manchmal daneben aber machen wir uns noch nichts vor es ladet doch eher in karlsruhe.
Und da dachte ich echt so wow das ist eine krasse aussage für den gewählten volksvertreter ja also du sagst halt gerade wissentlich dass du mit diesem gesetz die verfassung.
Wissentlich übertriffst.
Aber hey dafür haben wir doch karlsruhe ja also es ist tatsächlich wie du sagst eine art qualitätssicherung die eine eingepreist ist und,
die letzte episode ist jetzt ziemlich genau vier jahre später das war nämlich gestern ja ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen ich meine.
Wir wurden also mit wir meine ich jetzt reporter ohne grenzen und die die diese klage gemacht haben auch unsere beschwerdeführer ja die sich da irgendwie auch ihre namen gegeben haben und auch zeit investiert haben diese beschwerde zu führen ja es wurden dann
vertrauliche gespräche mit bmw mit führenden mitarbeitern zitiert in deutschen medien wo es allen ernstes hing man habe den verdacht dass hinter dieser verfassungsbeschwerde von den ausländischen journalisten auch ausländische nachrichtendienste,
stehen ja also ja ja.
Das musst du dir gefallen lass.
Und dann bist du dann denke ich.
Alter vater.
Dann sitzt du so dann sitzt du so auf dem sofa und dann schickt dir dein chef so so einen link zu so einem ich glaube es war die welt zu einem welt-artikel und liest du so,
naja es zeigt das muster von ausländischen nachrichtendiensten und es kann ja es kann ja sein es kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden das
und dann denkst du so okay jetzt meinen sie also mich dass ich ausländischer agent bin denke ich mir jetzt wo sind wir denn hier ja als würde wirklich so.
Richtig tief rein gegriffen und immer wieder mussten wir uns anhören dass wir terroristen schützen und dass wir,
dass wir überhaupt nicht verstehen worum es geht und dass wir die sicherheit von menschen gefährden also das hörst du diese vier jahre lang an.
Und gestern so zwei minuten nach dem urteil stellen sich vertreter der bundesregierung vor die kameras und sagen nee ist doch gut.
Jetzt wissen wir auch der bnd steht ja eh schon auf rechtlichen füßen wir werden das urteil umsetzen frage von journalisten
und wird das jetzt was an der sicherheit deutschlands ändern nein der bmw bleibt handlungsfähig wir können ja weiter überwachen es ist doch in unser aller sinne dass wir hier rechtsstaatlich handeln das ist alles kein problem,
ja also du hast gerade so eine harte klatsche bekommen hast immer getan dass die welt untergehen wird und dann sagst du so ja okay komm.
Gehen wir doch hin und das ist ja das ist unschön und das wird so weitergehen.
Also ich kann nicht ausschließen dass wir uns nicht hier in zukunft nochmal über eine weitere klage gegen einen bmw gesetz unterhalten werden.
Wenn ich mir das alles so anhöre
das lässt sich auch nicht ausschließen immerhin solange wir das gefühl haben dass das motto nicht lautet dreihundert prozent angestrebt hundertfünfzig prozent erreicht sondern dass es zumindest alles soweit im rahmen gehalten hat wie es möglich gewesen ist dann finde ich ist es auch schon mal
eine eine gute nachricht.
So geht halt dass sie sagt man so schön über die politik das bohren von.
Dicken brettern mit dünnen bohrern viel mehr als das was wir hier jetzt über wie viele jahre ist es jetzt her zwanzig dreizehn was norden also sieben jahre.
Es ist jetzt bald bei bald bald sieben jahre ich glaube zwölfter dreizehnter juni oder so.
Ich glaube dass es sogar heute losging dass er am zwanzigsten mai die in hongkong die dokumente übergeben hatte an petras und.
Das kann sein ja.
Wie heißt der.
In brasilien und dass das dass das diese ungefähr jetzt diese zeit als sieben jahre das haben wir dafür gekriegt.
Nein hätte auch weniger sein können.
Ich glaube es ist irgendwie gut aber geht er halt weiter ne also bundesregierung bleibt ja da von daher.
Gucken wir mal was er für eine bundesregierung dann kriegen wir das neue gesetz formuliert ist.
Ja also das wird die alte machen also.
Naja.
Aber was dann die neue auf dieser basis.
Ja ja das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht so weit gehen daniel mal ganz stellvertretend für alle die jetzt sozusagen an dieser geschichte gearbeitet haben danke für dein engagement,
und danke natürlich auch für die ausführung hier in dieser sendung weitere themen wenn wir jetzt hier nicht mehr aufgreifen weil es auch lang genug.
Hast du noch was hinzuzufügen hinaus.
Hätte ich mache ich nächste sendung.
Alles klar.
Okay also vielen dank daniel.
Sehr gerne vielen dank für die einladung.
Bitte und linus.
Vielen dank für jahrelanges engagement in dem bereich wir machen auch bald weiter tim na wir suchen uns den nächsten den nächsten geheimdienst den wir daran hindern können uns zu beschützen.
Genau wir haben ja nur nur im sinne aller handlungsunfähig zu machen dann war's das vielen dank fürs zuhören wir sagen tschüss bis bald.
Tschau tschau.